Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Sag mal Linus, wann verkaufst du eigentlich deine Gamestop-Aktien?
Die werden gehodelt.
Politik Nummer dreihundertachtundsiebzig vom Samstag, den was haben wir denn heute, den neunundzwanzigsten, nee, den dreißigsten ersten zweitausendundeinundzwanzig immer noch nicht verquatscht,
dem Jahr, es funktioniert, das funktioniert, es funktioniert.
Mache das am laufenden Band. Ich werde für mich die ganze Zeit, ich vertue mich die ganze Zeit mit dem, mit dem Datum. Aber vertippen, verquatschen nicht so, aber vertippen.
Hm. Mir passiert das nicht mehr. Vielleicht kommt das mit dem Alter. Die Altersdatumsweisheit.
Im Alter vergeht die Zeit ja schneller, ne? Du merkst, deine Uhr läuft ab und da kannst du die Jahre ja sehr viel schneller mitzählen, als äh als so ein junger Spund wie ich.
Du Hotshot. Ja, heute äh sind wir nicht alleine. Wir haben uns einen Gast dazu geholt und zwar den Daniel. Hallo Daniel.
Hallo Tim, hallo Linus.
Herzlich willkommen.
Resident Captainist haben wir zu Gast.
Genau. Jetzt muss ich gleich nochmal nachschauen, wann hatten wir dich denn das letzte Mal an Bord?
Ähm das ist ein Moment her,
dreihundertsiebenunddreißig war das. Und da haben wir so generell über die wirtschaftlichen Auswirkungen der Coronakrise gesprochen, damals als wir noch dachten, das wäre so eine kurzfristige Geschichte.
Wir haben in der dunkelsten Stunde gesprochen quasi.
Sind denn deine Vorhersagen, die du damals getroffen hast und an die ich mich jetzt nicht mehr erinnern kann, eingetroffen.
Ich glaube schon, ähm es war ein guter Zeitpunkt zum Investieren, dass definitiv ähm
Oh, dass ähm wir am Ende des Jahres sogar noch höher stehen als ähm vielleicht, wo wir ähm Anfang des Jahres gestartet sind. Das hätte ich wahrscheinlich nicht so prognostiziert, habe ich auch nicht. Das ist ähm ja, wahrscheinlich einmalig in der Wirtschaftsgeschichte. Ähm,
Ja, aber ansonsten, glaube ich, war das für ganz viele Menschen dann doch noch irgendwie zumindest an der Börse, ein erfolgreiches Jahr. Bei allem, was natürlich sonst ähm eher schlechten Dingen dann durch Corona äh auf der Straße passiert ist.
Also ich kann das kann man ja jetzt sagen, du äh managed ja den Fonds, allem Global Tico.
Und der äh den habe ich ja dann nach der Folge ein bisschen im Auge gehabt. Äh der hat sich ganz gut äh der hat sich ganz gut verhalten.
Der ist du was hattest du gesagt? Du bist hier, das ist einer, der jetzt in in den zehn Prozent der besten über diese Strecke jetzt oder wie war das? Äh.
Es gibt da so Bewertungsportale. Eins so, dass sich viele institutionelle Kunden angucken, also weiß ich, Pensionskassen oder Stiftung und sofort ist Morning Star und ähm dort ist der gehört zu den zehn Prozent weltbesten global anlegenden Fonds.
Alright. Deswegen durftest du auch wiederkommen.
Nur deshalb.
Du also das Gespräch hätte jetzt auch anders laufen können,
sagen wir's so. Aber obwohl wir den Hinweis äh gegeben haben und das ist ja etwas, wo du hattest ja gesagt, dass du immer darauf achten musst, ist kein äh Investment äh Rat,
oder keine Investmentberatung, was wir da gemacht haben, aber sie war, dafür war sie ganz gut.
Genau. Das gilt natürlich für heute auch, aber all das, was wir heute reden sollten, ist natürlich keine Investmentberatung. Ihr sollt alle selber entscheiden, worin ihr investiert und was ihr tut.
So ähm.
Aber Tim ist sicherlich in der Zeit Bitcoin Millionär geworden, oder? Der redet wahrscheinlich nicht mehr mit.
Tja, schön wär's. Schön wär's. Mir hat auch irgendjemand grade so eine Webseite äh zugeschickt, wo so,
Personen ähm geschätzt werden, was die denn so angeblich verdienen.
Völlig unklarer, totaler, so eine Skriping-Webseite, die sich offensichtlich ihre Informationen irgendwo herholt und dann so einen völlig kranken Algorithmus drüberläuft und äh,
wird mein Network mit irgendwie eins bis fünf Millionen Euro angegeben, keine Ahnung,
diese Information hier haben, aber ich kann das nicht bestätigen.
Ganz schön unterschätzt. Der ähm in dem Zusammenhang hat nicht der hier unser,
also das einer der größten Skandale der Bundesrepublik Deutschland äh Hans-Georg Maaßen dieser äh Rechtsaußen, der mal äh aus irgendwelchen Gründen, dass äh Rechtsaußen, Bundesamt für Verfassung, Verfassung,
äh äh da geleitet hat. Der hat jetzt irgendwie äh gehauptet, Jan Böhmermann würde neunzehn äh Millionen verdienen.
Weil das hat da auch irgendwo was weiß ich, im Kopf verlag oder so gelesen. Ähm würde mich überraschen, sagen wir's so.
Aber ähm schön, dass das äh also dass Jan Böhmermann mehr als Tim verdient ist, ja unwahrscheinlich.
So gut Zahl Spotify dann auch nicht wahrscheinlich.
Ich sage euch, die Zukunft liegt in kostenlosen Content. Das kaufen sie jetzt.
Ja, ähm sagen wir so, also wir sind äh also zumindest Tim und ich sind keine Millionäre. Ähm.
Aber es könnte daran liegen, dass wir ähm ja äh vielleicht auch keine besonders gepimpten Geschäftsmodelle verfolgen in in unserem Handeln,
anders als andere Leute, denen sehr viel nachgesehen wird. Und wird aber noch nicht einmal nachgesehen, wenn wir uns über eine neue App freuen.
Deswegen haben wir äh allerdings, muss ich ganz klar sagen, auch teilweise sehr äh nachvollziehbare, berechtigte Kritik zum Thema Klapphaus bekommen. Und ähm davon wollte ich jetzt einfach mal ein,
paar Feedbacks verlesen an den entsprechenden Stellen kann dann entweder Tim äh oder ich was dazu sagen, aber zumindest mal,
Breite möchte ich hier äh einmal auch wiedergeben
zwar ich hab jetzt nicht alle Kommentare genommen weil es waren wirklich relativ viele zu dieser Sendung viele haben sich auch jetzt Argumente wiederholt, deswegen habe ich dann jetzt einzelne ausgewählt,
der erste von Wall E.
Thema Klapphaus, halb ernst gemeint, halb überzogen, polemisch, aber nicht wirklich böse gemeint.
So, jetzt versuche ich jetzt mal so vorzulesen. Mich wundert ja, wie ihr bei Nutzung dieser App, ob der kreischenden, kognitiven Dissonanz,
überhaupt etwas verstehen könnt. Sorry, aber gerade bei der Stelle, warum ihr Sprachnachrichten per WhatsApp natürlich nicht als geeignete Austausch und Kommentarmöglichkeit zu diesem Podcast seht, aber dann jetzt Klapphaus dafür nutzen wollt, musste ich einmal kurz,
auflachen. Den ersten Teil der Sendung bringt ihr damit zu, die massenhafte Abwanderung der WhatsApp-Nutzerinnen zu Messenger zu begrüßen, deren Geschäftsmodell es ist, ihnen ein Messenger bereitzustellen.
Und nicht möglichst viele Daten über sie zu Profilen zusammenzufassen.
Im nächsten Teil werden dann Lobpreisungen auf das nächste große Ding an Social Network Kimble gesungen, bei dem komplett unklar ist, wie sie sich eigentlich finanzieren,
und es eigentlich klar ist,
dass hier das nächste Monster aus dem Schlamm erhoben wird, um in Zukunft unsere Demokratien zu gefährden. Das ist, glaube ich, dann der polemische Teil,
Äh ich mein, das Ding mit dieser ist doch auch vollkommen durchschaubar. Hier geht es nicht um organisches Wachstum und Communitybildung, sondern darum eine bestimmte,
bestimmten KPI und Daily User Zahlen zu erreichen, um sich dann möglichst bald dem Exit zu widmen,
und für viel Kohle an Facebook oder Twitter verkauft zu werden.
Generell finde ich das Konzept der App ja auch mega gut, ist halt Spontan-Podcast mit anfassen, aber gerade von Tim hätte ich eigentlich erwartet, dass da ein bisschen kritischere Töne angeschlagen werden, von wegen Podcastkultur, offen keine Zentralisierung, blieb bla blubb.
Ansonsten hätte ich jetzt gern nochmal erklärt, warum das Hosten von Exklusiv-Podcasts auf Spotify oder Audible ein Problem darstellt, aber das Etablieren eines Ökosystems von Meta und Communityfeatures,
rund um einen Podcast auf Klapphaus nicht. Lieben Gruß, ein Salty Android User. Ähm und ich muss sagen.
In meinen Augen äh in beide Punkte ziemlich genau ins Mark. Dass ich gesagt habe, unter keinen Umständen kommt WhatsApp in Frage, das kam ja von mir. Ich weiß gar nicht, dass es äh,
es gibt jetzt ja nicht die den des Gipfeltreffen äh von Linus und Tim, die große strategische Entscheidung treffen, deswegen weiß ich noch nicht mal, ob Tim was gegen WhatsApp Sprachnachrichten gehabt hätte. Das war so eine Linus äh Entscheidung, dass das nicht geht,
vor allem einfach auch, weil ich diese Software nicht verwende, das schließt das ein bisschen aus. Und ja, also der Punkt zählt. Ähm.
Also.
Ja, finde ich. Äh muss ich ganz klar sagen.
Denke mal also erstmal Sprachnachrichten hätte man natürlich auch anders organisieren können. Wir haben das ja auch schon mal gemacht mit Telefon oder äh man könnte mittlerweile haben ja eigentlich alle Messenger solcher Audiomöglichkeiten.
Das hatte auch jemand empfohlen, der dann sagte hier, dann nimm doch halt Signat Sprachnachrichten,
Wo ich dann leider sagen musste, ja Signal hat leider auch nur eine Identität, die man daran koppeln kann und es wäre äh also wenn es Multiple Identity Signal gäbe, dann hätten wir das auch genauso,
aber man kann eben nur einen einzigen mit einer Nummer perlen und deswegen äh geht das nicht, weil ich hier nicht meine äh Handynummer verwenden würde.
Problem ist nicht die Übertragung von einer Audioaufzeichnung. Da kann man auch in sein Mikro sprechen und und äh E-Mail schicken. Ich habe das
alles schon mal zu irgendeinem Zeitpunkt in irgendeinem Format ausprobiert. Das Problem ist die Gesprächsdynamik, die sich daraus einfach nicht ergibt
Das ist einfach äh man
sendet dann Monologe, das kann man machen, das funktioniert manchmal, aber meine Erfahrung ist einfach, es funktioniert nicht gut. Es ist nicht, nicht überzeugend, es ist nichts es ist auch das das
anhören, ist dann ein Prozess und das auswählen und willst es muss es unter Umständen nochmal zusammenschneiden, weil's zu lang ist und so weiter. Also es gibt einfach sehr viele Rahmenparameter. Ich habe das
äh fast nirgendwo, wo nicht erheblicher Aufwand getrieben wird
wirklich wirklich funktionieren sehen. Wäre das so, dann wäre es ja in vielen Podcasts der Fall, dass man das so macht.
Bleiben wir doch ganz kurz aber bei dem äh Feedback von Wally, der nämlich also der sagt, der einer der Primärgründe, WhatsApp nicht zu nutzen, wenn nicht der Einzige ist, dass die mit den Daten,
dass sie diese Daten dann Facebook zuführen ja? Und das Ding sich darüber finanziert das man eben Daten dort abliefert,
und nicht darüber, dass man für die Dienstleistung zahlt, das ist ja mein Kernargument und das ist bei Klapphaus nicht anders. Und da muss diese,
Telefonbuch hochladen Funktion ist absolut unter,
la Kanone und das habe ich ja, also habe ich ja zum Glück auch in der letzten Sendung gesagt, haben aber nicht alle, glaube ich, so mitbekommen, dass vielleicht der Tim und ich auch im Detail,
das unterschiedlich dramatisch bewerten.
Ja gut, ich meine, damals war auch noch ein bisschen unklar, was eigentlich genau passiert, dass da gibt es jetzt zumindest äh Erkenntnisse, also was eigentlich hochgeladen wird, es wird,
ausschließlich wenn ausschließlich die Telefonnummern hochgeladen, also keine Namen,
Das haben Security-Leute mit so lokal installierten Proxies und so weiter, keine Ahnung, was man da so äh nimmt. Diese Tage, aber es geht und das,
ist sozusagen ausgelesen worden, was tatsächlich über dieses Protokoll geht. Das sind sozusagen nur die Nummern. Und es ist natürlich hier ich sage nur, wie es ist
Das ist einfach der der Fakt, ja. Das kann man ja jetzt bewerten, wie man will, aber das ist das, was da passiert, ne. Es ist nicht das vollständige Adressbuch mit allen E-Mail-Adressen und so weiter wird übertragen, sondern es werden die Telefonnummern übertragen.
Ja und aber also ja, wenn du sagst, es werden nur die Telefonnummer ertragen, dann wird trotzdem übertragen, wer welche Telefonnummern hochlädt und dadurch entsteht ja dieses Netz,
Wer kennt wen?
Und wer hat wen eingeladen? Was äh zwei Qualitäten von äh also was Qualität über dieses Netzwerk sagt, nämlich mit dem einen hast du, okay, die kennen sich alle, die haben auf jeden Fall schon mal Telefonnummern getauscht. Und dann kommt noch der Aspekt, okay und von denen,
zweihundert Leuten, die die Person in ihrem äh Adressbuch hat, hat sie diese fünf eingeladen, ja? Und zwar hat sie wahrscheinlich diese fünf eingeladen, weil die anderen zwanzig schon drauf waren und das gibt die natürlich auch nochmal über die Qualität der ähm,
Connection eine Aussage, vor allem wenn du wenn du dann dazu hast wie das wie diese Menschen sich aufklapperst, dann weiterverhalten. Da werden einfach äh,
gute Metadaten über diese sozialen Gefüge auch miterfasst. Das ist so.
Aber ist nicht genau das der wahre Wert von Klapphaus und nichts anderes.
Super. Du, das äh das ist doch also du, du würdest ja auch sagen, dass das Ding sich jetzt äh zügig äh dass das verkauft werden soll, oder?
Ja, man ist ja jetzt schon mit einer Milliarde bewertet, also ich meine, was soll also sonst der wahre Wert sein? Also ich würde gerne mal denen das Pitch Deck sehen, wo drauf steht, wie sich das jemals rechnen soll. Also, ich meine, Abogebühr, Werbung, weiß ich nicht. Also, fällt mir schwer.
Nein, nein, Premiumdienste. Also es gibt einfach in, in, in, in der, in der, also, sie sagen ja auch ganz klar, dass sie auf keinen Fall Werbung machen wollen und sie sagen, auch,
klar, dass sie auf gar keinen Fall in den Daten weiterverkauf gehen wollen. Das ist derzeit ihre Aussage, ja, ob das so auf Ewigkeiten bleibt
keine Ahnung, ja, wer weiß, was er Aussagen über die Zukunft sind schwierig, aber das ist ihrer.
Und wer sich halt dort ein bisschen herumtreibt und diese Dynamik dieses Dienstes äh wahrnimmt,
merkt schnell, dass es hier erhebliches Potential gibt für echte Premiumdienste, also dass Leute bereit sind, sowohl auf der Anbieterseite als auch auf einer Konsumentenseite Geld zu bezahlen.
Anbieter, die sozusagen Clubs betreiben, die äh Edit Value Features
und so weiter, Analytics Clubfeatures und so weiter, also da sehe ich eine große Bereitschaft, Geld zu investieren, um sozusagen, was weiß ich, führende Firma da sozusagen so eine Sub-Infrastruktur zu erhalten
auf der einen Seite und auf der anderen Seite kannst du halt auch.
Panels äh äh Coaching, Sessions und so weiter äh Gesprächsrunden, mit Investoren und so weiter. Das ist halt auch etwas, wo Leute unter Umständen bereit wären, Geld dafür zu bezahlen. Also wirklich so wie so ein Konferenz
betrieb im Prinzip
also es ist nicht so, dass da jetzt nirgendswo Geld zu verdienen wäre, ob das dann am Ende funktioniert und ob das die Einnahmen einspielt und so weiter, das ist eine ganz andere Diskussion.
Also da kommen wir ja gleich nochmal drauf, auf diese Prämiefeatures und so, jetzt ist nur, glaube ich, zumindest kann man an der Stelle schon mal festhalten.
All das, was hier Audio und Räume und so weiter darstellt, das hat Klapphaus nicht selber gebaut, sondern dann nutzen die eine API, die andere äh so eine
eine ein Drittanbieter, den andere Apps auch nutzen. Das heißt, äh hier den gesamten Audiozinova haben die noch nicht mal selber gebastelt, ne? Und das,
heißt natürlich, dass die hier jetzt auch relativ wenig Exklusivität haben, weil die Funktion, die du jetzt grade benennst, sind eigentlich Funktionen von äh Agora, IO, die äh du eben quasi dir einfach dazu buchen kannst.
Also was äh ist das Serverseitige betrifft, genau. Es ist auch, glaube ich, es gibt noch einen zweiten Dienst, der da noch mit einer Rolle spielt, dessen Name mir gerade nicht einfällt. Ja, am Ende ist es ja die Kombination aus Bayern, aber es ist eben auch das, wie es alles in der App zusammenläuft. Also das ist,
ohne Wert in dem Zusammenhang.
Ich mache mal weiter, also Heinrichs Geist hat nur noch mal das also es ist ehrlich aber jetzt nochmal sehr schön ausgedrückt. Adressbuch, Hinterrücks und
und ohne Konsent absaugen. Das war für mich vor einigen Jahren der Grund, warum ich mich von WhatsApp verabschiedet habe, den Nutzern Privatsphäre absprechen, Verletzungen informativer Selbstbestimmung, Überheblichkeit gegenüber Gesetzgebern, heimliche und undurchsichtige Machenschaften und Täuschungsmanöver, das sind die,
Zepte der Überwachungskapitalistengeister, die wir doch,
Abzuschütteln versuchen oder etwa nicht. Und ja, ich würde, also ich stimme da zu und äh mir wäre dieses Klapphaus sehr viel äh sympathischer gewesen, wenn die einfach gesagt hätten, von Anfang an, Witze mitmachen kostet was weiß ich, fünf Euro im Monat.
Ähm bin ich bin ich bei.
Ja, aber hätte dann nicht so funktioniert, ist ja klar, ne?
Also das äh das ist, sagen wir mal auch der absolut gültige Kritikpunkt, ne, dass sie das nicht ausreichend vorher kommunizieren,
und auch äh kein Invitesystem vorsehen, nicht mal ein Einzelinwaltsystem ohne diesen Adressbuch Zugriff zu machen und dafür äh gehören sie kritisiert dafür
sind sie von uns kritisiert worden, auch schon von vielen anderen und dazu haben sie sich auch schon geäußert, dass sie das nämlich auch ändern wollen.
Das ist schön, dass sie das ändern wollen. Der Rambo-Radler hat aber, finde ich, einen wichtigen äh oder interessanten gesellschaftlichen Aspekt angebracht. Es gab ja äh,
Grundsätzlich das Ding funktioniert jetzt nur mit iOS und nur mit Invides.
Da haben wir gesagt, ja das wird eine temporäre Situation sein, weil selbstverständlich wollen die wachsen und werden sich auch in Richtung Android bewegen.
Aber Rambro Radler sagt, ich teile die Einschätzung, dass die Exklusivität von Klapphaus bezüglich iOS und Invice nur temporär ist. Allerdings halte ich diese,
In einem speziellen Bereich auch kurzfristig für Hochproblematisch. Mir fällt auf, dass viele hauptsächlich Konservative und liberale Politiker unter den ersten Nutzerinnen der Plattform sind.
Mit diesen stattfindenden Diskussionen werden als Bürgernähe im PR-Sinn verkauft. Faktisch ist es jedoch das exakte Gegenteil. Es findet eine Diskussion zwischen den Politikern und einer gefühlten Elite statt,
die sich aus Apple-Nutzerinnen und Invites äh konstituiert. Invatice konstituiert. Vor dem Hintergrund, dass gerade in der aktuellen Pandemiesituation von verschiedenen der Grad des Parlamentarismus kritisiert wird,
halte ich dies für eine gravierende Fehlentwirkung. Es entsteht der Eindruck eines Lobbyismus ohne Lobbyisten. Bei nur,
nur einige wenige Einfluss auf Parlamentarier nehmen können. Politiker sollten sich die Frage gefallen lassen,
ob eine solche Öffentlichkeitsarbeit für demokratische Prozesse sinnvoll ist. Spricht natürlich jetzt darauf an, dass,
viele Politikerinnen, Dorobär, äh,
Bodo Ramelow, Gerhard Schröder, äh und so weiter jetzt in irgendwelchen Klapphausrunden waren und du dann da ja tatsächlich die Situation hast, ne, dass eine,
also ich nehme jetzt irgendwie prototypische Beispiele, sagen wir eine zweiundzwanzigjährige Klimaaktivistin, einfach mal in direkten Austausch.
Äh einem Altkanzler treten kann.
Ja
Man erstmal denkt, das ist ja aber jetzt der Hammer, dass er nicht gesagt hat, hol mir mal eine Flasche Bier, sonst äh streike ich hier und mache nicht weiter, sondern tatsächlich äh mit der, mit der Person den Austausch äh getreten ist,
und da kann ich den Punkt von Rambo Radler auch verstehen, wenn da jetzt mal alle drin sind, dann wird das wahrscheinlich nicht mehr so sein.
Also mir ist das, ehrlich gesagt, das das hat mir zu viel Temperatur, diese Sichtweise. Das ist einfach
man kann es auch umdrehen, ja? Da ergibt sich jetzt ein Kanal,
Einfach und das ist echt meine Position. Eine sehr hohe Gesprächsqualität hat, ist einfach die die der Grad an Diskussionen.
Wie freundlich das da abläuft und wie inhaltlich das ist und wie informativ das ist und ich habe auch bis gestern Nacht fünf, sechs Stunden lang wieder Sachen
den ganzen Tag habe ich eigentlich äh Diskussionen gelauscht und ich bin einfach erschlagen von der Gesprächsqualität. Und das,
zu nutzen, jetzt wo es da ist, auch wenn es sozusagen nur ein durch technische Rahmenbedingungen
Bereich von Leuten ist. Dagegen spricht,
meiner Meinung nach einfach gar nichts, weil die Alternative ist, diese Art von Gesprächen nicht führen zu können. Letztlich sind das wie Besuche in Wahlkreisen, wo du einfach auch Leute hast und das ist auch
beschränkt, wer dahin kommen kann, durch geographische Bedingungen. Ich meine, wir haben,
Hörer eine Hörerrunde äh gemacht für Lokbuchten jetzt Politik, dafür gilt ja im Prinzip genau das Gleiche. Die Alternative wäre das halt nicht zu tun. Man kann nicht irgendwas dann so erst dann machen, wenn irgendeine,
theoretische, maximale Erreichbarkeit von allen erreichbar ist, weil die die kriegst du technisch sowieso nicht hin,
Gibt auch Leute, die einfach generell auf Internetkommunikation verzichten. Soll man deswegen das Internet nicht benutzen? Also das das halte ich eigentlich nicht für ein gutes Argument.
Okay, äh ich mache mal weiter. Laura.
Äh sagt, ihr habt Klappaus unglaublich viel mehr Aufmerksamkeit zugewendet als Signal und den anderen Messengern. Und das wirkt wie Werbung. Und das empfinden,
zumindest in diesem Fred, also Kommentarfread, schon mehrere Hörerinnen als unangemessen. Alternativvorschlag, lasst Klapphaus links liegen,
Tim hat es offensichtlich bereits mehr als gut genug getestet. Ruft stattdessen dazu auf,
diese Features in anderen freien Messengern oder Plattformen nachzurüsten und belohnt den Ersten, der das bietet mit einem kostenlosen Betatest.
Virtuelles Hörerin treffen.
Kann ich äh kann ich auch, also empfinde ich als konstruktiv. Im Gegensatz zu einigen anderen Kommentaren, die wir auch dazu hatten.
Ja, aber man muss einfach sagen, es handelt sich hier nicht um einen Messengerdienst. Hier werden überhaupt gar keine Sachen mit Store.
Haarspalterei, also das wird eine eine sauberer gebaute Konkurrenzplattform mit ähnlicher Usability wäre doch äh in aller Sinne. Ohne das Hochladen von äh Adressbüchern. Das das wollen wir doch alle.
Und und und diese das ist ja auch meine These äh äh diese Form der Kommunikation, die jetzt hier quasi neu aufschlägt,
werden wir an vielen anderen Stellen,
sehen. Ich meine, Signal hat auch tausend Sachen nachgerüstet, die auf anderen Sachen populär sind, so und all diese ganzen Sachen und Gruppenkommunikation und so. Ja, das das kommt alles, das das wird in irgendeiner Form dort auch äh stattfinden
so, aber,
Es geht ja hier um dieses neue Kommunikationsmodell an sich, was erstmal äh interessant ist. Und ich äh wehre mich einfach gegen diesen Begriff Werbung, weil er einfach die ganze Zeit immer so insiniert, man würde jetzt hier,
keine Ahnung, mit welchen Absichten oder vielleicht am Ende sogar noch gegen Bezahlung irgendwas ins positive Licht rücken. Wenn ich was gut finde, finde ich was gut, wenn ich was scheiße finde, finde ich was scheiße. So, es ist einfach so.
Mich nervt das ein bisschen.
Ich finde, ich muss sagen, dass ich jetzt also auf auf komme ich jetzt mal persönlich.
Werbeding ähm auch ein bisschen ähm.
Sagen wir mal ich will mal sagen ein bisschen verletzend finde weil wir hier seid wir werden in diesem Jahr unser zehntes Jahr Lokbuch Netzpolitik feiern, wir haben,
Irgendwann in der im äh dritten oder vierten Quartal, zehnjährigen Geburtstag und wir haben hier,
noch nie irgendetwas von euch verlangt und wir haben euch hier nie irgendeine Werbung eingespielt und ich bin ja auch selber werde ich ja nicht müde zu betonen, dass ich das auch für grundfalsch halte,
Aufmerksamkeit zu sammeln und dann an Dritte zu verkaufen, egal ob das Facebook ist oder Podcast-Werbung oder Fernsehwerbung oder sonst was,
und wenn ich mir anschaue, wie
Podcasts, die ihr sicherlich oder einige von euch sicherlich vielleicht auch noch hören, euch von oben bis unten mit bezahlter Werbung für sonst welchen Scheiß zuballern und euch bei jeder Gelegenheit noch irgendein,
was weiß ich
Unterlegscheibe für eine Schraube verkaufen wollen, wo das Podcast-Logo drauf ist, äh wo wirklich so jedes Objekt, was ihr in eurem täglichen Bedarf haben könnt, gebrauchen könntet.
Irgendwie monetarisiert wird und ihr euch den, was weiß ich, Podcast anziehen sollt, nur damit irgendwelche Leute mit
Gelaber, reich werden, ähm finde ich das dann schon auch ein bisschen krass, dass äh uns da, wenn man über eine neue App gesprochen wird und Tim da
etwas äh excited ist, äh dass dann so negativ ausgelegt werden muss. Andererseits äh.
Habe ich mir das dann auch so reflektiert, dass ich mir denke, ja okay, immerhin messen uns die Leute dann auch mal an den äh Werten, die wir hier vertreten und die wir,
für die wir stehen. Insofern, ja, finde ich, also ich komme mit dem Feedback klar und ich teile das zumindest in der Form, dass man äh.
Ich kann zumindest verstehen, dass einige Leute eben auch kommentieren, dass sie gewissermaßen enttäuscht sind. Aber jetzt kommt nämlich auch ein Punkt, der gerade äh ähm.
Schon früher angesprochen wurde. Ich glaube, das war äh einer der vorherigen Kommentare.
Wo gefragt wurde, na ja, wenn ihr das macht, warum macht ihr denn dann nicht bei äh bei Spotify oder Audible euren Podcast drauf? Und die Frage, denke ich, muss man sich durchaus gefallen lassen, das ist ja für uns auch eine,
eine religiöse Frage. Ich bin da regelmäßig an dem Punkt, dass ich mir denke, okay, dadurch, dass wir auf diese Plattform verzichten, haben wir,
auf jeden Fall Verluste in der unserer Reichweite,
also tatsächlich auch mit Leuten spreche, die sagen, ich liebe es, ich finde deinen Podcast nicht. Und dann da mit ihrem komischen Spotify hantieren und ich denen dann sagen muss, ja nee, das machen wir nicht, weil wir sind äh Fundamentalisten,
und äh wir wir haben lieber nicht, dass du uns hörst, als dass wir,
auf die Plattform kommen wo du bist und da bin ich muss ich jetzt auch sagen wenn ich jetzt den nächsten Kritik Sturm,
dass ich natürlich auch immer wieder versucht bin, den Tim nochmal zu fragen, ob er nicht vielleicht doch.
Uns diese Hörerzugänge auch sichern, weil mein irgendwann müssen wir Logbuch Netzpolitik ja auch an Facebook verkaufen und da geht's natürlich auch um bestimmte, die ähm,
die da gehalten werden müssen, ja.
Also.
Financial Independence Retair Early, ja?
Also es hat nicht unbedingt immer was mit Fundamentalismus zu tun, sondern es hat einfach schlicht was damit zu tun, dass ich mit den Termce of Service nicht klarkomme. Also wenn mir halt ein Dienst.
Aber bei bei Klapphaus tust du's, das ist doch der Punkt, der hier genannt wird und den.
Ich veröffentliche meine Podcasts nicht auf Klapphaus. Ich veröffentliche überhaupt nichts auf Klapphaus.
Wenn ich wenn ich in in äh Dollar Plattform meine Podcast einstelle und da steht dann drin wenn du hier deine Podcast äh veröffentlichst, dann äh räumst du uns folgende Rechte ein. Und da steht dann
immer irgendwie und wir dürfen da unsere Werbung einspielen. Sorry, dann finde ich das halt einfach ungeil.
Ich will nicht, dass die mit meinem Content dann irgendwie Geld verdienen,
Ich meine, Sie können ja auch sagen, wenn du unsere Plattform nutzen möchtest, dann musst du, was weiß ich, so und so viel Geld pro Monat zahlen. So, dann ist es irgendwie ein klares Dienstleistungsverhältnis
dann selber mir ausrechnen kann, was mir das wert ist
So, dann ist das irgendwie klar, aber ich äh möchte halt nicht, dass andere Leute ihre Botschaften in meine Botschaft reinschneiden. Das will ich einfach nicht.
Irgendwie, dass da äh albernes Zeug am Start ist.
Bei Klapphaus hast du davon noch viel mehr.
Nein, ich veröffentliche meine Podcasts nicht auf Klapp.
Ja, aber da dauert irgendwelche andere Leute dir rein.
Ich bin ja, das ist ja nicht meine mein Raum dann da so oder wenn ich Moderator bin, dann kann ich das ja auch selber moderieren,
handelt sich einfach um was vollkommen anderes, nur weil da irgendwie Stimmen zu hören sind, ist das ja nicht automatisch miteinander vergleichbar. Also da muss man auch wirklich mal jetzt ein bisschen unterscheiden.
Okay, dann äh kommen wir zum letzten Punkt. Äh da war dann, also wir haben ja in der letzten Sendung dann gesagt, dass wir eine Feedback-Runde zu diesem äh Podcast machen.
Aufklapphaus äh am Sonntag um neunzehn Uhr und ich muss sagen, wird jetzt keiner gerne hören. Das war eine äußerst angenehme Erfahrung. Wir haben äh eine Reihe an ja positiven und äh,
Negativem und ergänzendem äh Feedback bekommen, also durchaus wirklich auch inhaltliche Ergänzungen, die ich nicht ganz aufm Schirm hatte. Äh unter anderem ging es zum Beispiel darum, dass wir,
dass ich mich ja über die die Freundefinder Funktion von Facebook nochmal echauffiert hatte und da wurde dann nochmal die der tatsächliche Kontext ergänzt, dass nämlich damals die,
urteile, gar nicht unbedingt um dieses Hochladen von Kontaktdaten,
sich drehten, weil es die DSGVO in der Form noch gar nicht so gab, sondern vielmehr sich darum drehten.
Ähm dass es sich bei den E-Mails, die die Leute dann erhalten um unerwünschte Werbung handelt, also da so wirklich auch ne in der Korrektur und dann haben wir diesen,
Bodo Ramelow Fall besprochen, wo ja also Bodo Ramelow hat da offenbar äh abends in etwas ungezwungener Runde sich ein bisschen nicht von seiner besten,
Seite gezeigt, jetzt auch nicht besonders dramatisch, aber er hat irgendwie einen abfälligen Begriff für die Kanzlerin verwendet und,
äh so. Das hat ihn natürlich dann auch ein bisschen in den Allerwertesten gebissen, weil irgendwelche Weltjournalistinnen dadrin waren, die dann meinten, ha ha, jetzt können wir den wieder einen reinwirken und äh äh unsere AfD-Wähler irgendwie äh weiter aufstacheln und ähm.
Da hat sich dann eine relativ interessante Diskussion darüber ergeben, was ist jetzt wie wie verhält sich jetzt Pressefreiheit im Vergleich zu,
den Termce of Services und den Privacy Versprechen, was äh.
Äh Klapphaus ja offenbar seinen Nutzerinnen macht. So, dazu kommentiert dann Pseudonym,
in, also das ist ein etwas längerer Kommentar, ich nehme aber jetzt nur einen Teil raus, weil da natürlich die Frage war, okay, Logbuch Netzwerk sagt, wir machen Hörerinnen, treffen auf dieser Plattform, äh ist das jetzt okay oder nicht, weil da sind ja Leute ausgeschlossen.
Und in dem Kontext hatte Tim gesagt, na ja, wenn ich in der Bar das mache, dann habe ich ja immer ja auch keine Werbung für diese Bar, sondern ähm wir treffen uns halt dort. Irgendwo müssen wir uns ja treffen,
kommentiert äh Pseudonym Antworten drauf. Der Vergleich mit einem Hörertreffen in einer Bar hinkt, meiner Meinung nach, gewaltig, wenn ich echt will,
ich mich in einen Zug setzen, in eine andere Stadt fahren, um dabei, um dabei zu sein. Das Einzige, was ich davon abhalten kann, sind Zeit und Geld. Bei Clubhaus sind die Faktoren, ich muss eine Mobilplattform verwenden,
welche sich dadurch auszeichnet extrem teuer zu sein. Außerdem gibt es eine Reihe von er sagt jetzt also
er oder sie sagt, in moralisch moralischen Anführungszeichen Gründen sie nicht zu verwenden. Closed Sours, begrenzte Konfrontationsmöglichkeit
Abhängigkeiten von den von der Moralvorstellung eines Konzerns et cetera. Zu guter Letzt muss ich auch noch in der richtigen Ingroup sein, beziehungsweise mein Kontakt muss in hochgeladenen Adressbuch einer anderen Person sein. Alles in allem finde ich es enttäuschend,
dass ihr da mitmacht.
Ja, stimmt nicht, man muss sein Adressbuch da nicht hochladen und man muss nicht in irgendwelchen Adressbüchern drin sein.
Er sagt ja doch wie wie willst du denn sonst da reinkommen? Du bist dort, weil jemand.
Sinne, dass man eingeladen werden muss. Ja, okay, das ist richtig.
Jemand muss deine muss du musst in einem Adressbuch sein, was dort hochgeladen wurde.
Vielleicht einmal zwei, drei Gedanken, Tim, was du gerade gesagt hast. Ähm vom Geschäftsmodell her, klar, fallen mir auch tausend Zusatzfeature an, die man da einbauen kann. Aber wenn man jetzt mal abstrahiert,
geht es doch bei allen Diensten, die wir haben, doch darum, unsere Aufmerksamkeit zu bekommen, die es nur mal am Tage begrenzt. Also von Netflix über QB, die gescheitert sind über Podcast und so weiter. Und ich sehe tatsächlich nicht,
die Notwendigkeit, dass ich jetzt tatsächlich jeden Tag Klappos nutze, weil ich da so viel spannende Dinge finde. Also glaube nicht, dass es die Masse der Leute in der Form erreichen wird. Und wenn du sagst, irgendwelche,
Speaker oder sonst was, irgendwie Schulungen, die dort stattfinden, na ja, das kann ich jetzt per Zoom auch machen und Zoom kennen die Leute jetzt, glaube ich, X mal besser als irgendwie eine Klapphaus-App.
Da tue ich mich echt wirklich schwer zu sagen, daraus irgendwie ein Investment-Case zu machen. Und tatsächlich, wenn ich mal alle Bekannten frage, die es dort sind, die sagen, ja die ersten zwei Tage waren gut, jetzt sind sie da nicht mehr,
tatsächlich ist es so, ich nenne jetzt mal keinen Namen, aber einer der Top drei Wirtschaftsberatungen ähm per Diskret allen Mitarbeiter verboten, die selbst zu nutzen, einfach aus diesen Sicherheitsgründen, damit eben nicht die Telefonnummer von.
Wem auch immer dort irgendwie in diesem Netz halt irgendwie auftaucht.
Also dass sich äh das äh finde ich äh tatsächlich sehr äh verständlich und sinnvoll, weil es also es ist, wer wirklich in meinem Fall, ich hab's ja auch betont,
tatsächlich ein mittelschweres Disaster, mein Adressbuch da hochzuladen. Das kann ich nicht machen, kommt nicht in Frage. Es gab dann auch einige Empfehlungen, ja, irgendwie,
iCloud Sünking ausschalten, dann hast du ein leeres Adressbuch, dann fügst du die Leute hinzu, die du einladen willst, dann gibst du ein Adressbuch Zugriff, danach machst du den wieder aus, aber ja, das will ich doch nicht.
Kann's ja nicht sein, ja.
Und übrigens bei Twitter ganz am Anfang war's auch kuschelig und gemütlich und irgendwann wurd's dann auch da ein bisschen unruhiger. Also ich glaube, je mehr Leute da bei Klappers sind, dann wird's dann auch, egal in welche Richtung auch sicherlich ungemütlich werden.
Ja, aber ich meine ähm.
Muss mich das jetzt interessieren? Also das ist ja sozusagen nicht mein Problem, wie die sich jetzt refinanzieren. Erst mal.
Nein, natürlich nicht, klar.
Und äh ich bewerte das schlicht und ergreifend aus dem, was dort entsteht. So und äh,
wenn die Start-up-Club aus als solches morgen irgendwie wieder total äh crasht, weil sie da irgendwie keinen ähm Businessmodell für finden oder sich mit ihren Investoren verstreiten, na dann ist das halt so
Ich glaube halt nur, diese Art der Kommunikation wird bleiben.
Übrigens die beim damaligen ähm Kauf von WhatsApp für neunzehn Milliarden, wo jeder gesagt hat, es war zu teuer. Ich war übrigens glaube ich einer der wenigen, die gesagt haben, nee, es ist nicht teuer, ist sogar billig. Da hieß es ja auch erst in der AGBs, nee, nee, wir werden niemals äh mit Facebook Daten scheren. Und das war genau dann die Meinung damals. Es kann sich nur so refinanzieren. Und jetzt sieht man
ja mit allen AGB-Anpassung, dass da immer mehr Daten abgeschnorchelt werden.
Okay, wir haben dann, wenn eine App gehypt wird, das ist jetzt nicht Feedback, aber ähm äh ich bring's an der Stelle mal, weil wir ja jetzt schon wieder die ganze Zeit über dieses Klapphaus reden. Also wir füllen die erste Regel von Klappers auf jeden Fall sehr gut. Ähm.
Die App war neu und ähm natürlich schauen sich das dann Leute an.
Und äh du hattest das ja auch gerade schon erwähnt, Tim, das geht dann äh relativ einfach. Man möchte sich also den Netzwerkverkehr dieser App anschauen
sich raus, die benutzt halt äh HTTPS und äh oder also SSL äh verschlüsselte Verbindung
und sie hat auch Zertifikatspinning, so dass man nicht ohne weiteres ein MITM Proxi dazwischen bekommt. Ähm
kann man aber dadurch lösen, dass man halt einen äh Broken-Device nimmt, bei dem man das äh Zertifikatspinning ausschaltet,
und dann eben ein Proxi dazwischen hat. Und äh dann kann man sich relativ einfach angucken, dass diese App eben tatsächlich nicht viel mehr ist als eine,
eine UI und dieser ganze Audiokram wird eben über einen anderen Anbieter abgewickelt und das ist das,
Agora IO. Und da gibt's hier eine schöne Analyse von den Forscherinnen von Zerforschung Punkt ORG,
die äh direkt zweimal heute in der Sendung sein werden. Die haben sich also hier,
dieses äh Klapphaus mal angeschaut und haben festgestellt, dass dieses zugrunde liegende System,
Agora IO, was auch von anderen Apps verwendet wird, noch so ein paar andere Features hat, die Klapphaus, die jetzt in der UI nicht anzeigt, die aber das zugrunde liegende System hat,
Zum Beispiel das Mitschneiden von äh Gesprächen.
Das Mitschneiden von einzelnen Nutzerinnen getrennt. Ja, das wird ist für dich natürlich sehr interessant, Tim, ne? Stichwort äh Malta-Track Audio,
aber auch, also dadurch, dass die UI quasi auf Klapphaus-Servern stattfindet,
das Zusammenschalten von Audio auf Servern kannst du in einen Raum reingehen, den dann verlassen, aber weiter mithören,
weil du äh also um das jetzt mal leihenhaft darzustellen, dass du den Raum verlässt, teilst du der äh Club dem Clubhaus-Server mit,
und sagst hier übrigens, ich bin jetzt raus.
Und dann verschwindet dein Bild und du bist da wirst dann nicht mehr angezeigt. Du kannst aber weiter, du kannst aber in dem Raum drin bleiben, weil die du in Wirklichkeit ja die Verbindung über dieses Agora AO verwendet hast,
Also mit anderen Worten ähm dass da nur die Leute zuhören, die du siehst.
Ist äh nicht notwendigerweise der Fall. Du kannst auf jeden Fall, also es ist äh sehr einfach möglich und technisch problemlos wirklich, dass dir eben die Leute alle Leute, die wenigstens auch nur eine Sekunde drin waren,
auf jeden Fall auch äh zuhören. Und vermutlich kannst du das so schnell rein und rausgehen, dass es gar keiner mitbekommt, ne. Also jeder Kanal kann auch von Leuten gehört werden, die,
aber sich dort äh,
quasi äh noch ein bisschen äh an den an den dem, was dir angezeigt ist, vorbeibewegen. Ähm
Dann hat noch ein äh Hamburger Forscher äh bemängelt, dass es eine späte Drosselung beim Scraping der Nutzerinnen gibt. Also wo du wenn du einfach jetzt,
quasi von der API sagen lasst, wen gibt's hier, dass du da sehr viele bekommst bist dir irgendwann sagt OK geht nicht weiter. Das ist immer so ein Ja, weißt du, ich krieg da jede Drossel weg und selbst wenn die Drossel
besonders schwer ist, dann hole ich mir halt über Tor regelmäßig eine neue Identität oder habe genug Nutzer, über die ich scrape. Aber es ist ein Punkt, weil du äh hier,
relativ einfach dann eben auch das Netz bekommst, wer wen eingeladen hat, weil bei jeder Person steht auch immer dran, von wem sie eingeladen wurde. Das sind
Informationen, die du einzeln in der App sehen immer sehen kannst, ja? Gar kein Problem, aber die gewinnen natürlich eine andere Qualität, wenn du das halt irgendwie im Bereich zehntausender hast, ja?
Und äh man kann eben prüfen, äh wenn du eine Telefonnummer hast, kannst du halt gucken, ob die schon bei Klapphaus registriert ist oder nicht.
Oder ob eine Einladung besteht und so weiter. Äh also man sieht hier, das ist äh eher ähm.
Eher mit der heißen Nadel gestrickt. Jetzt würde ich natürlich aus Perspektive auch sagen so, na ja, dieses,
dass das Mitschneiden kannst du eh nur über die Terms of Service bremsen und ein besonderes Privacy Versprechen bei der Öffentlichkeitsplattform äh hast du ja eh nicht, insofern sind das also ja, sieht einfach, man sieht einfach nur hier, dass das halt,
besonders stabil steht diese Software, aber irgendwelche tatsächlichen Angriffe auf die Nutzerinnen,
die jetzt, sage ich mal, realistisch sind, wurden hier jetzt eher nicht gezeigt, aber ähm ähm.
Man sieht auf jeden Fall, dass hier die die Magie, die du ja auch äh äh denke ich zurecht benannt hast, wie wie problemlos das Audi da funktioniert, das haben die eben gar nicht selber gemacht, sondern dann nutzen die einfach einen dritten Service.
Ja, also an der Stelle, was ich ein bisschen problematisch finde, ist, dass das äh Systemdesign an der Stelle tatsächlich so ist, dass dieses Token, was man quasi,
erhält, wenn man den Raum einmal sieht, auch gilt, wenn man den Raum wieder verlässt. Das wäre,
es scheint mir dann sozusagen so ein globales Raum token zu sein und das ist natürlich bekloppt,
denn äh man würde davon ausgehen, dass jeder User quasi ein per User Token bekommt und wenn das System sagt, so der ist jetzt nicht mehr dabei, dass das dann eben automatisch verfällt. Warum ist das problematisch? Also grundsätzlich sind ja die meisten Räume öffentlich, aber,
ja auch private also es gibt ja so drei verschiedene Raumkonzepte, es gibt so einen komplett öffentlichen, es gibt komplett
wurde eben nur bestimmte Leute einlädst und es gibt die sogenannten Social Rooms, wo,
alle reingehen können, denen du folgst. Und wenn jetzt einer reingeht und wieder rausgeht, dann ist natürlich die Erwartungshaltung der Leute,
die sich dort noch unterhalten, dass diese Person nicht mehr da ist. Und natürlich dann Sachen.
Sagen, die sie vielleicht in Anwesenheit dieser Person nicht gesagt haben.
Das soll man aber ohnehin nicht machen.
Das ist aber so. Und.
Ja, also äh ja, das sind sicherlich Dinge, äh wo sich noch Diskussionen entwickeln werden.
Kleines, technisches Detail der der Token ist tatsächlich nutzerinspezifisch, aber er er läuft nicht ab,
die äh die Agora API bietet dir offenbar nicht die Möglichkeit, also den du kannst nur einen Token erstellen, du.
Revoken. Okay, alles klar, also ein AP Problem. Mhm.
Okay, dann gab's noch ich äh hoffe, dass jetzt sind wir mit diesem Klapphaus endlich durch und jetzt ab jetzt ist Klapphaus verbot. Ähm.
Ab jetzt gelten wieder Fightclub-Regeln, wer ist no Clubhaus? Und ähm es gab noch einen ähm einen Kommentar, der.
Dem ich gebe denen jetzt mal einfach so wieder von Stefan, der sich nämlich nochmal ein bisschen mit der Digitalisierung, der Gesundheitsämter auseinander äh gesetzt hat. So, der Kommentar geht folgendermaßen. Linus hat ja angemerkt,
dass es mit der derzeitigen Geschwindigkeit kaum Auswirkungen auf die Pandemie hat, was die Gesundheitsämter da machen.
Digitalisierung ist dabei eine mögliche Lösungskomponente. Leider gibt es noch mehr Aspekte. Ich möchte das mal beschreiben. Jetzt muss man gut zuhören.
Vorweg muss man sich jedoch eine Sache klar machen. Das Besondere an Covid ist, dass die Infizierten schon zwei Tage vor der Erkrankung infektiös sind.
Das ist ja mittlerweile fast Allgemeinwissen. Was nicht so präsent ist, ist, dass es etwa vier bis fünf Tage dauert, bis ein frisch angesteckt.
Selbst wieder ansteckend wird,
Das ist das sogenannte serielle Intervall. Also du hast den Kontakt, dann dauert's vier bis fünf Tage bis du ansteckend bist und weitere zwei Tage bis du erkrankst.
Wenn ich mich also anstecke, dann laufe ich mindestens bis zum Tag der ersten Symptome zwei Tage ansteckend herum,
Wenn mich kein Scout des Gesundheitsamtes ermittelt und in Quarantäne steckt, das heißt aber auch, dass wenn ich selbst symptomatisch werde, es nur noch zwei Tage dauern darf, um meine Kontakte in Quarantäne zu schicken, damit die Kette unterbrochen wird.
Dafür werden also sechs Phasen durchlaufen. Erstens, ich muss checken, dass ich einen Test brauche, ich muss einen Test bekommen.
Drittens, ich muss das Ergebnis bekommen. Viertens, das Gesundheitsamt muss das Ergebnis bekommen.
Die Scouts müssen Kontakte ermitteln und die Kontakte müssen dann in Quarantäne gehen oder getestet werden. Eine Menge Holz für zwei Tage.
Bei Punkt eins ist digital nicht viel zu machen. Auch ein Schnupfen kann eine Covid-Erkrankung sein, daher sollte die Aufklärung sein, geht im Zweifel zum Testen,
Punkt zwei, geht raus an die Ärzte und Teststationen, testet die Leute, egal wie banal die Symptome sind. Bei Punkt drei kommt die Warn-App ins Spiel. Sie übermittelt das Ergebnis aktiv.
An die Infizierten. Kein gelegentlicher Abruf von einer Webseite, kein Warten auf den Anruf vom Hausarzt. Das wird zu wenig kommuniziert,
dass da ein paar Stunden viel ausmachen können. Nicht für den Getesteten, aber für seine Angesteckten.
Beziehungsweise deren durch Quarantäne verhinderte Opfer. Das gibt einem beim ersten Durchdenken einen Knoten erziehen. Vielleicht,
auch deswegen nicht schnell genug gearbeitet. Punkt vier. Offiziell sind die Gesundheitsämter ab dem zehnten ersten verpflichtend ans Demis angeschlossen und das sei digital. De facto, sind aber die Infizierten, die von uns angeleitet wurden, ihre Kontakte ans Gesundheitsamt zu melden?
Vielfach abgeprallt, weil das Gesundheitsamt ihr Ergebnis noch nicht registriert hatte. Da gibt es dann so Antworten wie vielen Dank für die Übermittlung ihres positiven Befundergebnisses, da uns die Befunde von manchen Teststationen erst mit Verzögerung erreichen,
Beten wir sie uns ihr positives Testergebnis an die E-Mail-Adresse zu übermitteln, sobald es ihnen auch schriftlich vorliegt. Das sind natürlich äh ähm.
Probleme. Ja, ich versuche das jetzt ein bisschen ähm kürzer zu fassen. So, nee, das schaffe ich nicht. Also.
Okay, also und bevor das erledigt ist, startet aber auch kein von den Gesundheitsämtern. Das heißt, sie wissen eigentlich, dass sie schon loslegen könnten, aber sagen erst, wenn wir das hier,
wirklich auf Papier haben fangen wir an mit unserer Arbeit. Traumhaft ja? Dann musste Erkrankte erreicht werden um ihre Kontakte zu ermitteln zu können. Da gibt es aber leider auch
Tisch auf Kopfgeschichten dazu, dem Gesundheitsamt liegen zwar die Meldedaten zu, aber regelhaft keine Telefonnummern,
Da hat man sich was cleveres ausgedacht und hat auf den Laborschein ein Feld für die Mobilfunknummer geschaffen.
Diese werden aber in einem Drittel der Fälle nicht eingetragen, weil das Feld für die Telefonnummer optisch eng mit der Einverständniserklärung für die Warnapp verknüpft.
Die Ärztin haben also absichtlich keine Nummern angegeben, weil sie dachten, dafür würde die App benötigt. Hatte der Proband keine App,
auch keine Telefonnummer, also doppelt lame, ne. Da hat die App, beziehungsweise das digitale Analphabetentum vermutlich einen Beitrag zum Unterhalt der Pandemie geliefert, welcher natürlich schwer zu beziffern ist. In der Regel,
Telefonnummern dann bei den Hausärztinnen erfragt. Da kann man sich vorstellen, dass dies mindestens wieder einige Stunden dauert, bis sie dann vorliegen. In vielen Bezirken ist es jetzt eine recht Bauern, ist jetzt eine recht Bauernschlaue Regelung in Kraft getreten.
Positiv, Klammer auf, es geht immer noch nur die langsame PCR Getestete sollen ihre Kontakte selbst informieren und in Quarantäne schicken. Unter Anleitung
Hausärztin gelingt das erstaunlich gut. Zusätzlich sollten die Kontakte sich noch so schnell wie möglich
testen lassen, um festzustellen, ob sie bereits auch als Virenquelle unterwegs waren oder noch sind.
Fazit, das R setzt sich also zusammen aus den Lockdownregeln und der Effizienz des Effizienz des contact-Tracings,
Das ist derzeit noch am schnellsten, wenn die positiven selbst ihre Kontakte karantänisieren und zum Testen schicken? Das funktioniert vermutlich schon digital,
über WhatsApp.
Fand ich mal äh tatsächlich einen schönen Einblick da rein, dass ja, am Ende wird's den ganzen Scheiß hätten sparen können und sagen würden, waren einfach deine Leute und da hätte man keine Corona-Warnapp gebraucht, sondern da.
Corona-WhatsApp.
Corona-Hotel.
Ja. Ja, es ist ein ist ein ist ein Drama. Also diese hochbürokratischen Prozesse, die für die es sicherlich viele äh gute Gründe gibt,
sind einfach für diese Pandemie nicht gemacht. Und hier muss extrem,
optimiert werden in diesem Prozess und das unterstreicht im Prinzip auch nochmal, wie gut eigentlich die Idee der Corona-Warn-App ist.
Nur die Bereitschaft dieser Gesellschaft da einfach mitzuspielen ist begrenzt, so wie sie auch leider begrenzt ist beim Umsetzen der Maßnahmen
Ich glaube, dass die beschlossenen Maßnahmen an sich funktionieren würden, das halten sich halt bloß nicht alle dran. Das ist das Problem. Und deswegen haben wir
die Situation, die wir haben.
Schön dargestellt, was wir dann auch nochmal aufgefallen ist. Also es gibt eigentlich auch keine erfolgreich skalierende App, die mit einem Blatt Papier anfängt, wo was drauf geschrieben werden muss, ne. Also das müsste
Da kann man von Klapphaus lernen, ja? Einige Leute haben auf Twitter auch schon die App vorgeschlagen. Äh da da sehe ich auch noch auf jeden Fall Potential.
Vor was soll die jetzt baden?
Vor Leuten, die ihre Adressbücher da hochladen.
Siebzig Milliarden gespart.
Okay, ein jetzt ein letztes Feedback und dann kommen wir endlich, endlich äh zum zum ersten Thema. Ähm,
Wir hatten über die Cookiebanner gesprochen. Dazu hat äh Marcel uns einen Link zu einem.
Urteil des Landgerichts Rostock dagelassen wo es nämlich genau um das beim geht Landgericht Rostock wie gesagt das ist ja dann noch relativ,
ähm niedrig angesiedelt, aber was die hier äh geurteilt haben, oh, wo ist er denn? Moment.
Funktioniert der Link nicht. Äh jetzt muss ich das aus dem Kopf äh äh sagen, dass sie im Prinzip gesagt haben, so hier ähm,
Das, was ich letzte in der letzten Sendung auch dargestellt hatte, ne, dass du fünfmal klicken musst und der eine Button hervorgehoben ist und der andere nicht. Und da du,
diese Dinger eben, selbst wenn du die Änderungen vornimmst,
Änderungen übernehmen, weiterhin grau bleibt und alles akzeptieren, immer schön knallrot grün da bleibt und das wurde hier äh spezifisch äh geurteilt, dass sie gesagt haben, so wie das hier bedeutet äh ähm dargestellt ist von der Nutzerführung her,
Einwilligung nicht wirksam. Und das ist natürlich ein sehr schönes Urteil, weil das bedeutet, dass selbst wenn du auf diesem Wege dir die,
die Einwilligung der Nutzerinnen per Klick geholt hast, ist nicht erfüllt die Anforderungen der DSGVO in Form. Das war ja ein wichtiger Aspekt, dass man gesagt hat so.
Der muss du musst die Zustimmung erteilt haben und du musst sie informiert getroffen haben. Nicht einfach, ja, ja, ich habe das gelesen, sondern,
musst auch wirklich äh aktiv informiert worden sein. Und da hat jetzt das Landgericht äh äh Rostock eben in einem Urteil äh äh geschlossen, dass
diese Anforderung nicht erfüllt ist und damit ist dann auch die komplette Datensammlung und was da noch alles an Raubmohrtracking äh passiert ist, äh illegal. Ja und das ist, denke ich, auch genau das Urteil, was man auf,
auf den man hier hoffen muss, damit diese unsägliche Praxis ein Ende hat.
Deswegen danke an Marcel für äh dieses Urteil.
Und das gilt im Prinzip für so neunundneunzig Prozent äh aller Webseiten, die ich so gesehen habe, ist es äh wirklich eine Vollkatastrophe. Und ich hoffe, dass das alles ganz schnell weggeht jetzt.
Ja, Rostock.
Lob, Lob an Rostock.
So, damit hätten wir jetzt den äh Feedback-Blog durch, der ja dann doch jetzt etwas länger war, ähm aber wir haben ja Kapitelmarken, da hätte ich vielleicht auch vorher nochmal sagen können, aber.
Nächste Mal wisst ihr Bescheid. Ihr hättet das alles gar nicht hören müssen.
Ja. Der eine überspringt den Werbeblock, der andere sich ein Feedback-Blog.
Die Werbeblöcke haben in der Regel keine Chapter Marx. Da wissen sie schon, das vergessen die immer. Das steht in den in den Verträgen.
Ja oder sie sind nicht so genau gesetzt und so und dann musst du halt nochmal die letzten dreißig Sekunden anhören.
Bedauerlicher Fehler.
Dark Patterns überall. So und da müssen wir echt mit einem großen Hammer drauf hauen.
Werbung muss eh weg, aber dass das äh haben wir ja. Erwähnt. Okay, endlich.
Daniel, ich habe gehört, der die heiße Aktie ist Gamestop. Ja und.
Jeden Fall.
Wir müssen jetzt, jetzt wissen wir verstehen warum ausgerechnet ein Laden der physische,
Computerspiele auf ähm anachronistischen Darreichungsmedien verkauft und in der Pandemie ohnehin äh unter Umsatzeinbußen leidet.
Auf einmal mehr wert ist, was weiß ich als der als der deutsche DAX, nein das ist noch nicht ganz, aber aber signifikante Raten hat und du,
als ähm Fondsmanager kennst dich ja mit diesen ganzen Börsenspiel ähm aus.
Und deswegen haben wir uns gedacht, äh werden wir dieses Phänomen mal ganz in Ruhe von vorne bis hinten beleuchten und ich glaube,
fängt am besten damit an zu erklären, was eigentlich shorton ist oder gibt's noch etwas äh wissen wir noch noch noch früher anfangen?
Ne, vielleicht nur einen Schritt zurück, ähm äh was du bei Gamestop erwähnt hast und das ist vielleicht irgendwie wichtig, in in der Geschichte. So wie du's richtig zusammengefasst hast, klar, kann man das über dieses Geschäftsmodell streiten und sagen, hm,
da ist irgendwie nicht viel Wert drin, wer kauft ihm noch ein Spiel auf CD? Ja, vielleicht noch ein Plüsch Mario und das war's dann, das macht ja alles keinen Sinn mehr
Tatsächlich gab es eine Zeit und die Aktie war ja mal irgendwie bei vier Dollar gewesen
das auch eine Form des Investings, wo man tatsächlich rechnen konnte. Äh also die Aktie notierte unter ihrem Buchwertung. Das heißt also, der Buchwert ist ja das, was ich sage, physisch in so einem Laden irgendwie vorfinde, also,
die Regale, ähm vielleicht gehört ihr nochmal hier unter an den Store und das ist der Buchwert und die Akzeptierte aber unter diesem Buchwert. Heißt, wenn ich die Firma zerschlagen würde und das alles verkaufen würde und wir nehmen an, ich habe keinen Abschlag darauf, dann würde ich natürlich einen Gewinn erzielen. Und.
Stop, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, Stopp, halt, halt, halt. Da ich in dem Privileg ganz privilegiert von dieser Geschichte nahezu nichts mitbekommen habe diese Woche war ich.
Weil du den ganzen Tag auf Klapphaus hängst, mit anderen Sachen beschäftigst, du tust so als hättest du was zu tun.
Unter anderem auch das. Ja. Ich habe mich über wichtige Sachen unterhalten.
Von da äh also lass uns kurz die Ausgangssituation nochmal genauer schildern. GameStop ist ein Unternehmen, das sitzt wo.
USA.
Also Gamestop ist eine Kette von Spieleläden. Und zwar äh ich ich meine eigentlich nicht nur,
Computerspiele, aber natürlich primär Computerspiele,
und die findest du in äh also die sind eigentlich schon relativ groß und die findest du in vielen Mals und das ist das ist halt der Laden, wo du reingehst und dann ist da die PlayStation Ecke, die Xbox-Ecke und dann haben sie natürlich
um viele Computerspiele wie Daniel gerade auch schon sagte
errankt sich eine Kultur, ne, dann kannst du dir halt einen Plüsch-Mario oder einen noch kaufen und eine lebensgroße Lara Croftcraft aufblaspuppe mit äh,
naturgetreue Anatomie und was ich alles, ne, das kannst du dann alles irgendwie.
Also so quasi so für für Spiele, für Computerspiele, so.
Und jetzt muss man einen Aspekt noch dazu sagen, den den ich, glaube ich, vergessen habe, warum gerät dieses Geschäftsmodell in Straucheln? Weil die neuen Plattformen, also,
PlayStation, Xbox und so weiter haben angefangen, auch Appstores zu machen. Und ähm die neueren Systeme, die Xbox,
oder was und die PlayStation fünf sind,
in der billigeren Variante kommen die sogar schon ohne CD-Laufwerk. Oder was die da nutzen Blu-Ray wahrscheinlich. Das heißt, der Markt für optische äh Medien oder überhaupt für physische Medien,
in dem Gaming-Bereich findet seit Jahren sein Ende. Also auf dem PC ja auch mit Steam
und ähm das hat also hat natürlich für die Nutzerinnen auch die Komponente ja ist schön und gut, du kannst du musst nicht mehr in den Laden gehen, aber du hast natürlich auch diesen Zweitwert Zweitmarkt, äh der dir dann verloren geht für das äh Abdrehen von den von den gebrauchten Spielen.
Man könnte also jetzt befürchten, dass es so den Weg von von Blockbuster geht, die ja sozusagen auch auf physischen Medien so Filme verliehen haben und dann halt einfach innerhalb weniger Jahre komplett vom Markt verschwunden sind.
Sagen, dass diese PlayStations und den Tennis dieser Welt natürlich beim digitalen Download mehr Gewinn machen, als wenn ich die Kopie irgendwo im Saturn schiebe oder zum Gamestop. Also
Nintendo zum Beispiel auf vierzig Prozent aller Nutzer laden sich die Spiele runter. Darauf hast du ähm von irgendwie, weiß ich, siebzig Prozent und im Laden im Saturn nur von fünfundvierzig Prozent, also die haben durch hohes Interesse daran, dass du's dir da irgendwo runterlebst.
Die Mittel meinen natürlich dann aus der Kette rausnimmst.
Das ist für dein, für dein Gamestop-Geschäftshotel natürlich super schlecht, wenn deine Primärlieferanten ein riesen Interesse haben, dass du eingehst. Ja.
So und das ist der der Case bei bei einer GameStop gewesen von den Leuten, die sagen, hm, das Geschäftsmodell ist tot und darum daddelte die Aktie irgendwann mal bei vier Dollar rum und war halt irgendwie fast pleite gewesen,
Aber bei diesem, wo die Aktie so günstig war,
man aber auch argumentieren zu sagen, was ich gerade mit Buchwert meinte, also wenn ich eine Läden nehme, das ganze Inventar und was da noch alles so rumsteht, dann war die Aktie billiger als das, was ich nun physisch da in so einem Laden vorfinde.
Und es gibt eine Sorte von Investoren, die sagen, das ist genau der richtige Case für mich, wenn ich alles zerschlagen würde, dann bekomme ich mehr Geld raus. Lass uns mal im Raum stehen, ob,
denn wirklich man da so viel Geld für bekommt, das kann man jetzt alles rechnen oder auch eben nicht. Und somit gab's natürlich dann Investoren, unter anderem gab es den ähm,
den äh CEO, dem äh gehörte, das ist glaube ich so eine Lutscher-Company
der ähm damit relativ viel Geld, ob zwölf Komma neun Prozent von von Gamescom weiter gekauft wird, eingestiegen ist und hat gesagt, so ich mache aber alles hier ganz toll. Aus Gamestop mache ich ein Portal und da kann man sich auch demnächst die Spiele,
elektronisch runterladen. Und ab da war die Aktie natürlich dann ein Stück weit beliebt. Sie soll wieder gestiegen, weil die dachten, na gut, wenn jetzt jemand kommt, der auch schon in der Vergangenheit viel Erfolg hat und da Geld reinsteckt, vielleicht kann ja was draus werden. Das war so im letzten Jahr so die Ausgangssituation.
Dass bis dahin erstmal alles gut. So, was natürlich dann jetzt passiert ist, exakt, was Linus gerade sagte,
es gibt natürlich so Listen wo man sieht wer auf solchen Film überall ist und gut vielleicht sollte man erstmal erklären was irgendwie bedeutet also leer verkaufen.
Ein Spiel, das eben mittlerweile jeder privat mal auch betreiben kann. Früher war's nur großen Kunden, also wir wie ich als Vormanschaft vorbehalten, was jetzt aber auch ihr bei Konsors oder bei jeder anderen äh Direktbank äh betreiben könnt. Und zwar, wenn du der Meinung bist, dass,
morgen weniger wert ist im Aktienkurs als sie heute ist, dann
leihst du dir diese Aktie, das heißt, du gehst zu deiner Bank und sagst, ähm hier ich möchte mir gerne die Aktie ähm äh leihen, meinetwegen tausend Stücke. Ähm dann sagt die Bank klar, kein Problem,
ähm hier hast du diese Aktie, dafür zahlst du eine Gebühr, meinetwegen fünfhundert Euro und dann gehst du wieder nach Hause und hast jetzt erstmal tausend geliehene Aktien,
Und diese geliehene Aktie, die dir nun wirklich nicht rechtlich gehört, verkaufst du an dem Markt.
Wenn die Aktie, meinetwegen bei hundert steht, verkaufst du also im Gegenwert von hunderttausend Euro. Wenn sie bei neunzig steht, dann sagst du prima. Jetzt decke ich mich das Ganze wieder ein, also bei neunzigtausend,
Sprich, wenn ich meine fünfhundert Euro Kosten nur abgezogen habe, ähm wenn ich das dagegen rechne, dann gebe ich die Aktien der Bank zurück und habe neuntausendfünfhundert Euro verdient als Beispiel.
Verkrampft grade sein Gesicht, ich mach's nochmal, ich mach's einfacher, Tim. Ähm nehmen wir deinen Wohnwagen, ja?
Leih mir deinen Wohnwagen gegen eine Mietgebühr, ja? Und wir haben einen festen Termin, wann ich dir den zurückgeben muss,
ja? Und ich weiß jetzt aber, dass diese, dass ich den Wohnwagen bis zu dem Termin im Zweifelsfall billiger kaufen kann. Das heißt, ich kaufe dein, ich leihe mir deinen Wohnwagen und verkaufe den.
Und habe jetzt,
Im Prinzip habe ich etwas verkauft, was mir nicht gehört. Ich schulde dir aber jetzt einen Wohnwagen. Und jetzt kaufe ich mir, weil die Preise für Wohnwagen fallen.
Bis zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo ich dir den wiedergeben muss, möglichst günstig den gleichen Wohnwagen, gib dir den zurück,
und die Differenz streiche ich ein. Das heißt, das mache ich dann, wenn ich weiß, ey, der Wohnwagen ist heute zu teuer und morgen kriege ich den billiger?
Dann leiche mir den, verkaufe den und gib dir nachher, wenn ich zum Stichdatum, wo ich ihr dem wiedergeben muss,
billigeren zurück und streicht die Differenz ein. Das ist im Prinzip diese Technik ermöglicht es mir, nicht nur Akts auf Aktie auf das Steigen von Aktienkurse zu wetten, sondern auch auf das Fallen. Wenn es das nicht gäbe,
könntest du immer nur auf steigende Kursen wetten, ja? Und das ist ja blöd, du kannst ja genauso gut sagen, wenn ich ein Wissen habe, dessen Kurs fallen wird, ähm,
dann kann ich das nicht monetarisieren, es sei denn, ich mache genau das. Ich schorte die Aktie. Also, ich leihe mir die, verkaufe die, kaufe sie später günstiger und gebe sie dann zurück, streiche die Differenz.
Also im Prinzip ist es eine Wette äh auf die Zukunft, dass ein Aktienkurs fällt.
Alternative zu dem Standard, ich wette darauf, dass er äh steigt, dann würde ich sie mich sofort kaufen,
Aber da ich ja sozusagen nichts jetzt kaufen kann, was dann dadurch mehr wert wird in der Zukunft. Äh.
Verkaufst es jetzt schon mal und kaufst es nachher billiger.
Kaufe ich mir, ich kaufe mir sozusagen das Recht, die Dinger in Zukunft zu verkaufen, aber zu dem Preis äh im im Verhältnis zu dem Preis, wie er jetzt ist.
Nee, nee, du verkaufst sie auch tatsächlich. Du leistest die, verkaufst die und schuldest dann zum Stichtag dem anderen musst du ja das geliehene zurückgeben.
Ja, aber ich muss dann nur das bezahlen, was in der Zukunft wert ist.
Ja und das ist genau das Problem, weil das, was die in der Zukunft wert ist, wenn das niedriger ist, hast du den hast du die Differenz eingestrichen. Aber wenn es mehr wert ist, schuldest du die Aktien zum neuen Kurs.
Das Bittere oder das das das äh Spiel der.
Na was heißt Schulden? Also du musst einfach nur die Aktion zurückgeben, was natürlich bei dir passiert ist, ist klar. Du musst die Aktien irgendwann mal wieder zurückgeben und dann ist natürlich die Frage, was du dafür für da bezahlst am Markt. Und klar, wenn der Kurs höher steht, dann hast du natürlich ein Problem.
Genau, du schuldest nämlich, du schuldest natürlich die Aktien und kannst nicht nachher sagen, ey, guck mal, ich habe die ja damals für zehntausend von dir gekauft, äh, geliehen. Ich würde sagen, ich gebe dir die zehntausenden, wir sind quitt. Ne, und dann sagen die dadurch
nee, nee, nee. Ich hatte hier zehn Aktien und nicht zehntausend Euro. Und wenn ich eine Aktie kaufe,
dann kann ich immer maximal hundert Prozent verlieren. Ne, und zwar alles Geld, was ich da reingesteckt habe.
Wenn ich eine Aktie schorte, sind meine theoretischen Verluste unbegrenzt.
Die Aktie kann sich ja, wenn sie doppelt so teuer ist, sind meine Verluste hundert Prozent.
Aber wenn sie zehnmal so viel kostet, hm.
Mal so teuer ist, sind meine Verluste vierhundert Prozent. Das heißt, die Verluste beim sind theoretisch nicht begrenzt. Und das ist wichtig äh zu wissen bei diesem Spiel und,
Da du einen Stichtag hast, wann du die zurückgeben musst.
Musst du diese Verluste auch realisieren. Wenn du eine Aktie kaufst und sagst okay, Scheiße, die hat jetzt grade neunzig Prozent Verlust, dann kannst du einfach sagen, okay, Hode.
Halten, halten, halten, das kommt nochmal hier. So, ne? Ähm.
Das heißt, was im blödesten Fall in diesem Wohnwagen Beispiel passieren kann, ist, nach vier Wochen will der Tim seinen Wohnwagen zurückhaben
der Tim hat dir aber auch noch eine Gebühr abverlangt, das heißt also, im Worst Case, wenn der Wohnwagen den gleichen Preis hat, also am am Markt sozusagen, hast du deine Gebühr verloren, die Tim von dir verlangt hat oder wenn der Preis steigt, klar, dann bist du natürlich erst recht gekniffen.
Und das wäre, ne, jetzt zum Beispiel, wenn ich deinen Wohnwagen shorte, dann kann das zum Beispiel.
Ich habe mir den extra gekauft, weil der so groß ist. Jetzt machst du ihn kleiner.
Wenn ich wenn ich deinen Wohnwagen shorte.
Zum Beispiel auch so Saisoneffekte geben, ne? Der sich denkt, die Dinger, die die Preise für Wohnwagen gehen die ganze Zeit runter, aber in Wirklichkeit liegt das daran, dass jetzt irgendwie Oktober ist, ja? Und ich schotte deinen Wohnwagen bis März, ja und auf einmal mehr
Lockdown vorbei, alle wollen wieder raus auf den Acker. Die Wohnwagenpreise explodieren und ich denke mir, Scheiße, ähm.
Okay.
Das ist.
Lass uns
dann zurückkommen zu GameStop, das heißt, wenn ich das jetzt richtig interpretiere, dadurch, dass das sozusagen eine Firma ist, der ein Geschäftsmodell allgemein eh so ein bisschen EOL, Ad of Life mäßig angesehen wird und jetzt auch noch die Pandemie dazu kommt, haben sich ein paar Vögel gedacht
die gehen bestimmt äh in den Keller. Da äh schorte ich doch jetzt mal, also ich leih mir sozusagen Aktien, damit ich die dann ähm später äh
verkaufen kann, aber dann eben zum niedrigeren Preis.
Und die Differenz dann entsprechend als Gewinn einbehalt exak,
das, das machen vorwiegend, seien wir in der Form, je nachdem, aber als Geschäftsmodell halt Hedgefonds. Und das passiert natürlich nicht nur bei Gamestop, sondern das finde ich bei ganz vielen Aktien, ähm AMC, also diese Kinokette als Beispiel, äh war mit auch in der Schusslinie gewesen, Blackberry,
Großkopfhörer. Also es passiert an allen Ecken und Kanten und ist auch nicht unüblich. Also es gibt schon seit etlich.
Öffentlich? Ist das ist das ist das etwas, was von dem der Markt dann weiß, wie viele dieser Shorts existieren oder ist es irgendwie, also woher weiß man, dass dass sowas passiert?
Es wird veröffentlicht, also nach der Finanzkrise ist man tatsächlich nun, ich weiß nicht, ob es für jedes Land gilt, aber zumindest in Deutschland ist es so, verpflichtet, ähm als ähm also da, wo der Fond lagert, auch entsprechend an einer Stelle zu melden, wer wann, wo wie Short ist. Das, was man durch nicht weiß, ist jetzt
Also man weiß es nur als stichtagsbezogen, aber ich weiß natürlich jetzt nicht, wenn ich jetzt deinen Wohnwagen Short verkaufe, dass der Kontakt irgendwie in vier Wochen endet, das weiß natürlich niemand. Aber Stichtagsbezogen weiß schon eine gewisse Stelle zu dem Stichtag, wie viel Grad jemand schaut es?
Und nicht wer, sondern nur in der Gesamtsumme,
und das kann ich natürlich dann nachlesen bei Blumberg oder jetzt in meinem Fall bekomme ich jetzt tatsächlich jeden Tag irgendwelche Listen von irgendwelchen Brokern für französische Unternehmer, sonst wem, wo die Leute halt sind.
Also Stichtag ist jetzt, der wo das Leihgeschäft gemacht wird oder wann, wann sie wieder zurückgegeben werden müssen.
Man sagt einfach, Stichtag ist dann mal das Quartalsende und zum Quartalsende. Was ist die Gesamtsumme an Aktien, die ähm wo jemand ist?
Ach so, okay. Mhm.
So aber das natürlich, dass es eine Stichtag bezogen ist, kann natürlich sein, dass es schon längst wieder verkauft worden sind oder was auch immer. Mal zurückblickend ist und nicht in Zukunft ist.
Funktioniert das Spiel so.
Ein großer Hedgefond geht macht ihr geht in irgendetwas und sorgt dafür, dass es möglichst die Welt weiß.
Damit alle Schiss haben und denken, oh shit, der große Hedgefond schortet meine schöne Aktie. Ich verkaufe die jetzt mal lieber, weil wenn die darauf wetten, dass die in den Keller geht, werden die wahrscheinlich etwas wissen, was ich nicht weiß.
Also verkaufen Leute alle und allein die Ankündigung, dass irgendjemand eine Aktie schortet, kann,
potentiell oder ein großer Fonds, eine Aktie schortet, kann halt zur äh selbsterfüllenden,
Prophezeiung werden. Ne, was ja ist ja immer bei Aktienmärkten so, dass man dass das Wissen über das Handeln anderer potenziell auch das eigene Handeln.
Ähm beeinträchtigen kann.
Das funktioniert natürlich in beiden Richtungen, also äh sagen wir bei Wirecard hatten die die Short waren logischerweise recht,
Bei mir im Beispiel so, es gibt eine deutsche Firma da gibt's auch einen, der irgendwie, wie du grad sagst, einen langen Bericht über hundert Seiten veröffentlicht hat und sagt, was alles da schlecht ist. Klar, die Aktie fällt natürlich, das bist du in der Beweislast, ich kenne nur das Unternehmen seit zwanzig Jahren, also,
kann man nie mit hundertprozentiger Sicherheit sagen, dass das alles nicht stimmt, aber ich gehe ganz schwer davon aus und dann hast du natürlich erstmal einen riesengroßen Reputationsschaden.
Und plus natürlich Nebeneffekte, du musst dich vielleicht refinanzieren, das ist teurer. Die BaFin ist da jetzt angerückt und macht irgendwelche Sonderprüfungen, die Kosten musst du auch selber tragen und, und, und.
Wer muss die tragen?
Wenn die BaFin sagt, ich möchte dich heute prüfen, lieber Tim, wenn du ein Finanzunternehmen wärst, dann trägt nicht die BaFin die Prüfungskosten, sondern dann trägst du die Kosten.
Also als Fonds, der jetzt Short äh Selling betrieben hat.
Das Unternehmen, was äh.
Du davon betroffen bist, genau, exakt. Ja, genau.
Davon betroffen ist. Okay.
Also wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstanden habe, Daniel, also es gibt dieses Unternehmen und jemand hat gesagt, ich schorte das und hat groß dargestellt warum.
Und diese, das ist jetzt irgendwie eine eigene Recherche oder so, ja und äh dann hat die BaFin hat das gelesen, hat gesagt, oh krass, äh könnte was dran sein. Jetzt machen wir da mal eine Prüfung bei diesem Unternehmen.
Attacke ist das dann, ne?
Ja, exakt genau so, natürlich im Zuge dessen, dass es jetzt eine zweite deutsche äh Unternehmen war, im Zuge nach Wirecard. A hat natürlich jeder in Deutschland verkauft, weil jeder Vormittag sagte, ups
Ich möchte es nicht auch noch vielleicht doch einen zweiten Wirecard-Fall im Fond haben und die BaFin eh schon angeschossen ist. Ähm Damian sagt, okay, das gucken wir uns jetzt mal alles hier ein bisschen genauer an.
Jetzt wird sich natürlich zeigen über Zeit, ob das stimmt oder nicht. Viele, also Dinge konnten schon entkräftet werden. Aber klar, als Unternehmen hast du natürlich jetzt erstmal ein Problem.
Und dem ist das scheißegal, weil der hat die der hat äh der kauft dann günstig die Aktien, er füllt seinen Deal, reibt sich die Hände, dass er ein letztendlich von einem,
Dass ein Aktienkurs, den er prognostizieren konnte oder vielleicht auch beeinflusst hat, äh auch tatsächlich eingetreten ist. Ickelig, ickelig ist das.
Nochmal ganz kurz, weil jetzt ins Jahr zweitausendzwanzig nochmal ins letzte Jahr guckt, dann ist natürlich tatsächlich ein Jahr, worzeller tatsächlich erste Mal relativ wenig verdient haben,
Also der prominenteste Fall ist natürlich Tesla. Ähm allein die USA haben Shorts ja im letzten Jahr zweihundertfünfzig Milliarden zirka verloren, allein mit Tesla vierzig Milliarden,
Das ist natürlich genau so ein Ding natürlich und das ist auch der Grund, warum Elo Mask natürlich so fleißig jetzt bei Twitter unterwegs und sagt, hier prima, liebe reddit, user, ähm gib doch mal da Vollgas, ich hasse Shortzeller, klar, weil er natürlich auch selber davon profitiert, dass seine Teslakte nun da steht, wo sie halt eben steht.
Und das ist übrigens auch die selbsterfüllende Prophezeiung in die andere Richtung,
Also ich meine, es können wir so viel über Tesla reden, wie wir wollen. Ähm aber sicherlich ist sie nicht das wert, was wo gerade der Aktienkurs steht, aber was passiert natürlich? Er sagt auf dem hohen Kurs,
prima, ich mache eine Kapitalerhöhung, also sammle nochmal Geld vom Aktienmarkt ein. Das heißt, wenn sie fast vorher pleite waren, haben sie jetzt auf einen hohen Kurs irgendwie sich eine Menge Geld aufs Konto gelegt und jetzt sind sie halt erstmal irgendwie sicher, dass es funktioniert in die andere Richtung halt.
Kapitalerhöhung kannst du auch nochmal kurz erklären, was das genau für ein Vorgang ist.
Also wenn jetzt du mit deiner Miete eben an die Börse gehen würdest, dann würdest du ja, sage mal, ähm fünfzig Prozent deines Unternehmens nach außen geben und andere Leute können deine Aktien kaufen und dann würdest du ja entsprechend Kapital dafür bekommen,
das gleiche passiert auch wenn du schon an der Börse bist und sagst ähm ich möchte jetzt noch mehr Aktien an den Markt geben und sammle dafür nochmal extra Geld ein. Das nennen wir dann Kapitalerhöhung. Das.
Ach so, man gibt einfach zusätzliche Aktien raus. Also man verkauft einfach mehr Anteile. Okay.
Also da, wenn dein Unternehmen, wenn du weißt, dein Unternehmen ist gerade überbewertet,
Verkaufst du natürlich die Unternehmensanteile, um diese theoretische um diesen theoretischen Wert irgendwie zu realisieren? Die Unternehmensanteile, die du verkauft hast, hast du dann aber auch in Geld da, um deinen Unternehmenswert tatsächlich zu steigern.
Also du,
Und das machst du also wenn du weißt, du bist überbewertet, dann versuchst du natürlich äh erstens die Gewinne zu realisieren und zweitens dafür zu sorgen, dass diese Valuation auch tatsächlich zutrifft. Und dass das ist die ganze Zeit, glaube ich, der Grund, warum oder was,
warum die Tesla-Aktie,
die ganze Zeit so schön überbewertet ist, weil du, weil die eben davon profitieren können und damit auch immer wieder mehr machen können und immer wieder überraschen können.
Genauso geht es dann auch in die andere Richtung, das heißt, wenn ein Unternehmen der Meinung ist, äh ihr Aktienkurs ist unterbewertet, dass sie dann auch selber so solche Byeback-Programms machen, dass sie selber äh,
quasi wieder zurückholen ins Unternehmen, weil sie denken, die steigen sowieso wieder äh billiger kriege ich das nicht und dann kann ich ja später immer noch Kapitalerhöhungen machen, wenn ich sie nicht haben will.
Ein ganz guter Manager für Unternehmen bist, machst du es macht du es exakt so wie du es sagst, wenn du überbewertest bist, zahlst du beim Kauf entweder mit deinen eigenen Aktien, also weiß ich nicht, Salesforce kauft, irgendwie Slack, aber zahlt dich mit Cash, sondern sagt, hier kriegt eine Salesforce Aktie, ist natürlich super, wenn sie hoch steht,
Genau und wenn du denkst, deine Aktie ist unterbewertet, dann kaufst du sie zurück,
Du hast aber so einen Fall wie Apple, ähm die haben so viel Cash. Wir sagen, wir müssen so oder so irgendwie äh Aktien zurückkaufen, wo natürlich auch dann dann der und der Gewinn pro Aktie am Ende des Tages halt eben steigt.
Ja, weil sie dann auch die Nachfrage nach der Aktie erhöhen und damit den Kurs auch wieder hochtreiben, was dann wiederum gut ist für die Mitarbeiter, die sie mit Aktien bezahlen und so weiter, ne.
Dreht sich im Kreis, okay. Ja, wollen wir dann mal auf den konkreten Fall Gamestop kommen? Also, wir haben jetzt dieses Unternehmen
Dass eben so schlechte Aussichten hat, ne, Pandemie und auslaufendes Geschäftsmodell, der drohende Blockbuster Style äh tot. Jetzt kommen irgendwelche Hedgefons und sagen,
Ah, der. So, die werden jetzt bestimmt bald verenden. Jetzt verwenden wir diese Methode, diese Short Sellings, weil wenn dann der Kurs zu einem bestimmten Datum dann auch tatsächlich gefallen ist, dann machen wir ordentlich Kohle dabei.
Exakt.
Was aber dann passiert ist, was auch schon im letzten Jahr teilweise bei Tesla passiert ist, dass sich Leute im Internet natürlich jetzt über sowas austauschen, insbesondere hier in diesem Fall bei Redit. Das gibt's auch auf Discord gab's Gruppen zu diesem Thema, also an unterschiedlichen Stellen, aber,
allen voran dafür verantwortlich sicherlich ist, ist sicherlich McGredid, auf dem sich vorwiegend, sage ich mal, junge Nutzer treiben, die sagen.
Da gibt's unterschiedliche Motivationen, die sagen, diesen ganzen Hedgefonds, den müssen wir jetzt irgendwie das gar ausmachen und äh versauen denen das Geschäftsmodell und haben sich zusammengetan so, so sage ich es jetzt mal ähm um sagen, wir kaufen die Aktie jetzt aber,
also die einen haben die Aktie leer verkauft und die kaufen die Aktien natürlich nach oben, führt natürlich dazu,
Was wir gerade hatten, wenn der Preis deines äh äh Wohnwagens, den Minus, der zurückgeben muss, natürlich jetzt höher steht, dann ähm wird natürlich versuchen, den schnellstmöglich da irgendwo ähm einzudecken. Was natürlich dazu führt, dass die Aktie extrem schnell nach oben schießt, weil,
Es kaufen Leute aus diesem Forum, plus auch noch Leute, die sich in dem Shot mit der Aktie wieder eindecken müssen. Also, das nennt man Shorts-Quiz, also steigt die Aktie quasi kerzenartig entsprechend nach oben.
Diesen Short Squeeze, das ist das ist das, das Faszinierende daran. Das muss man, glaube ich, nochmal genauer sagen. Also, wenn du weißt, viele Leute haben diese Aktie geschortet.
Dann weißt du auch in einem bestimmten Zeitraum oder bis zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt müssen die diese Aktie kaufen, die haben keine andere Wahl,
die die Verbindlichkeit haben, diese Aktie denen wieder zu geben, von denen sie sich die Geliehen haben. Und insbesondere, wenn die gestiegen ist, wollen die,
von denen sie sich die Aktie geliehen haben, die auch sehr gerne wieder haben. Ja, weil die wollen die ja potenziell jetzt verkaufen.
Mit anderen Worten, wenn eine Aktie zu viel geschortet ist, weißt du, du hast garantierte Käufer.
Und das heißt potentiell, wenn du dann hingehst und sagst, wir treffen jetzt kollektiv die Entscheidung nicht zu verkaufen.
Dann bedeutet das, dass diese Schorter auf einmal da sitzen und die müssen die Aktie kaufen, zu egal welchem Preis.
Ja und sie müssen natürlich, wenn du alte Headshow bist, natürlich irgendwann mal nach oben hin auch die Verluste begrenzen, ne? Also wenn du die Aktie jetzt zu hundert gekauft hast, die steigt jetzt aber auf zweihundert, dann hast du dich einen riesengroßen Verlust. Also irgendwann bekommst du da irgendwie weiche Knie.
Und die haben halt, also die haben irgendwann keine andere Wahl mehr, als das zu egal welchem Kurs zu kaufen. Und weil sie das wissen, kaufen, versuchen sie natürlich im Zweifelsfall noch zu einem niedrigen Kurs zu kaufen. Also früh,
Das versuchen aber alle, was bedeutet, der Preis geht hoch. Ein wunderschönes Spiel.
Und das ist jetzt passiert. Also eine äh eine rettet Community oder eine Community, die sich irgendwie auf reddet austauscht, hat jetzt entdeckt durch diese,
verpflichtenden Meldungen, dass dieses Short Selling bei Gamestop wohl besonders stark war.
Und ähm ich meine, sind denn diese Hedge Fronts jetzt eigentlich so per se nutzlos,
generell böse oder erfüllen die eigentlich auch irgendeinen Zweck
also kann man jetzt so die generell einfach so hassen oder äh haben die nicht irgendwie so wie Geier sich aufs Aas äh werfen auch so eine gewisse ähm ökonomische Sinnhaftigkeit.
Ja das ist eine gute Frage. Denn insbesondere dessen, was man in den USA jetzt sieht, dass jetzt,
Politiker einschlagen auf diese jungen Leute, die sich da in äh sammeln. Das ist natürlich total eine einseitige Betrachtung. Also wenn ich die als böse darstelle, sind Hedgeforce natürlich wenn in dem gleichen Spiel genauso böse.
Zumal man übrigens diesen,
ähm diesen Reddit-Usern auch gar nicht äh rechtlich nachkommen kann, denn es ist zwar verboten sich zu versammeln und Dinge rauf und runter zu kaufen, aber sich bei REDIT zu treffen, zu sagen, ich finde Gamestop gut oder schlecht, das wiederum ist natürlich irgendwie erlaubt. Also ich glaube, rechtlich wird da erstmal nicht viel passieren.
Gut oder schlecht oder braucht man sie für irgendetwas? Ich meine.
Was natürlich dadurch passiert, dass ich natürlich Dinge und darauf setze, dass Unternehmen fast pleite ist, wird natürlich dazu, dass, sage mal, Bereinigungsprozesse viel schneller passieren,
Ich glaube, dass einfach die also das ist mir so die Argumentation von Hedgefonds, gibt auch viele Studien dazu, die genau das belegen. Es führt einfach zu einer Bereinigung von einem Markt.
Tatsächlich ist es so, in der jetzigen Coronakrise ähm wo alles Mann und Maus unterstützt wird, ist es natürlich so, dass eben grade nichts pleite geht. Also.
Mit einem Unternehmen gesprochen, das sag ich ähm was Marktführer in einem Bereich ist und sagt, warum kauft ihr nicht jetzt in der Krise andere Unternehmen auf? Und die Antwort darauf ist, können wir gar nicht, weil wir nichts Billiges bekommen, weil niemand Pleite geht,
Das heißt, da draußen laufen gerade auch eine Menge Zombiefirmen rum, die vielleicht auch schon hätten vor Corona nicht überleben müssen. Und klar, so ein Hedgefond kann natürlich sowas verstärken, um den Markt einfach hier zu bereinigen.
Plus, das ist noch Effekte gibt in so einem Aktienportfolio, also,
ich mein Aktienfond als Beispiel, setze dir nur auf steigende Kurse, ich könnte jetzt auch, sage mal, die Schwankungsbreite, die so ein Fond hat, also wie sich ein Kurs rauf und runter bewegt, natürlich auch abfedern, indem ich tatsächlich auch eine Short-Position mit reinnehmen würde und könnte das Risiko etwas mindern. Also es hat auch solche.
Portfolio Optimierungseffekte quasi, aber das, glaube ich, ist eher zweitrangig.
Aber hier gibt's ja jetzt schon so seitens dieser Community so eine so eine generelle Dämonisierung. Weiß man denn von diesen Meldungen
welche Hedgefonds das sind oder weiß ist das nur eine also weiß man überhaupt, wer der Short-Zeller ist oder weiß man nur dass es Shortseller gibt.
Es gibt im Edgefonds, die eigentlich regelmäßig veröffentlichen, was sie tun, also eine Art Newsletter, sage ich mal, ganz witzig, jetzt ein, zwei Große haben gesagt, wir werden das nie wieder veröffentlichen, die haben daraus gelernt
eine der bekanntesten jetzt, der jetzt äh mit hoch kam, ist ein ein Melvin heißt der Hedgefond,
seit zweitausendvierzehn gab es mal eine Statistik, hat ja jedes Jahr eine Rendite von dreißig Prozent abgeliefert, ist irgendwie so zwölfeinhalb Milliarden groß geworden und allein dieses Jahr hat das schon dreißig Prozent Verlust eingefahren, nämlich genau durch diese äh.
Ja, also das Airport bei Gamestop war und entsprechend dann jetzt mit Verlusten eindecken musste. Der hatte über Nacht tatsächlich mit so einem Deal jetzt vier Milliarden verloren, also war fast pleite gewesen,
und ähm dann kamen es zwei befreundete Hedgefonds, haben gesagt, weißt du was, wir kaufen irgendwie einen Großteil deiner Firma und geben dir halt entsprechend diese vier Milliarden. Das sind so einen Fall, der irgendwie entsprechend.
Also das man muss vielleicht jetzt noch ein bisschen äh darauf schauen, wie aberwitzig die Ergebnis hier sind. Also Gamestop war Anfang des Jahres irgendwo bei zwanzig Dollar oder so.
Und die sind jetzt äh schwanken die irgendwo bei dreihundertfünfzig.
Jetzt wusstet ihr natürlich für diese überlegen die haben die für einen Zwanni gekauft und gedacht, dass sie die vielleicht für neunzehn oder achtzehn danach kaufen, ja oder vielleicht siebzehn.
Aber die müssen sie jetzt halt für dreihundertfünfzig kaufen. Und das ist äh natürlich ruinös, weil die mit, weil sie sich so in ihren Wetten so sicher waren,
ne? Und eigentlich gedacht haben, okay, wir haben hier vielleicht zwanzig zehn, zwanzig fünf Prozent todsicheren Gewinn. Und jetzt haben sie tatsächlich,
ähm ein äh todsicheren Verlust von äh von einem Vielfachen des des ursprünglich äh investierten.
Äh vielleicht sollen wir nochmal kurz äh weiß man denn wie viele Aktien Schott, also kennt man den Umfang oder ist das gibt's nur für das weiß man. Okay und wie ist der?
Also das ist ja, jetzt wird's natürlich nochmal eine Spur perverser in dem ganzen Spiel. Ähm ich kann eigentlich mehr Aktien leer verkaufen als eigentlich Aktien existieren. Und das ist tatsächlich grad der Fall bei Gamestop. Also die Frage ist halt, wie das Spiel jemals erstmal enden soll.
Also wenn ich.
Musst du erklären, weil also das also Gamestop war geschortet um einhundertzwanzig Prozent. Jetzt musst du mir nochmal erklären, was das genau bedeutet.
Das funktioniert eben ähnlich so ein bisschen wie mit diesem Geldmengenwachstum, also wenn der Tim tausend Euro zur seiner Bank bringt, zum Sparen, dann,
verleiht die Bank ja nicht dem nächsten Kunden nur tausend Euro, weil sie tausend Euro bekommen hat, sondern sie kann ja dann deutlich mehr über diese tausend Euro verleihen. Und so ist es halt auch mit dem mit dem Shortzeller. Also,
Ein der verkauft seine Aktien am Markt und findet ein Käufer, der sie wiederum einem Nächsten gibt, der wieder damit geht und somit kann ich natürlich unendlich entsprechend natürlich Shortpositionen halt aufmachen.
Und somit konnte es natürlich mehr als zu hundert Prozent kommen, wobei man das hier auf dem Float auch betrachten muss. Also nehmen wir mal irgendwie in der Amazon, die natürlich im Großteil ähm äh Jeff Bezos gehört,
Das heißt also es sind ja nur die Aktien im Umlauf, die eben nicht Jeff Bezos gehören. Und die, die ihm gehören,
die wird da wahrscheinlich auch nicht verleihen, also das heißt auch die Leute, die gar nicht daran teilnehmen, die verknappen das Ganze natürlich auch noch.
Also das heißt Hedge Force haben.
Anderen Hedgefonds oder äh anderen Anlegerinnen oder Banken einhundertzwanzig, also ein ein Fünftel Gamestops geschuldet, während man auf dem Markt ohnehin wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal einen halben Gamestop kaufen könnte, wenn man alle Aktien nimmt.
Und deswegen konnten ein paar User dieses äh redditforum, in dem diese Diskussion ja stattfinden, ist äh hat ungefähr eine Millionen Subscriberinnen.
Wenn das halt Fahrt aufnimmt und auch nur ein paar tausend oder zehntausend äh oder hunderttausend Leute, weißt du, wie viele da mitgemacht haben?
Ich sehe, ich ich habe nur gerade mal Blumberg noch mal nachgeschaut. Also der Sharefload, das was wirklich handelbar ist in fünfzig Millionen und aktuell, wobei natürlich jetzt, wie gesagt, stichtagsbezogen, dass nicht zwangsweise stimmen muss, sind zweiundsechzig Millionen.
Zweiundsechzig Millionen war's Dollar, Aktien.
Anzahl der Aktien genommen.
Okay.
Also man weiß, dass dass, Moment, das heißt, wenn alle diese Short Deals auslaufen, können die gar nicht alle befriedigt werden oder sind die ja auch wieder ineinander, dass es schon irgendwie klappen kann?
Man kann das taggleich sicherlich auflösen, aber es muss natürlich dann auch jeder entsprechend bereit sein, die Aktien wieder abzugeben und zu kaufen et cetera.
So und das sieht jetzt im Moment nicht danach aus. Es ist so ein bisschen so also es ist so ein so ein Kaskadeneffekt halt,
das ist so als wenn du morgen Kredit bei der Bank aufnimmst, kaufst dir ein Haus und spielst dieses Spielchen unendlich weiter, weil dem Minus vertraut man ist super, es hat auf fünf Häuser und noch mehr Kredite und eines Tages sagst du aber ich kann's ja nicht mehr bezahlen, dann fällt das ganze Kartenhaus natürlich zusammen.
Um nochmal ein bisschen so die die Kontinuität hier rein zu bekommen. Mein Hirn ist am arbeiten. Also äh
ähm Krise, Pandemie und irgendwie Branche schwach, jetzt kommen die Headfonds und sagen so da machen wir doch jetzt mal Kohle und wir wetten jetzt sozusagen auf einen bestimmten Zeitpunkt in der Zukunft, weiß man, welcher Zeitpunkt in der Zukunft das so im Schnitt
ist dann.
Die Verträge sind unterschiedlich, aber sie sind sicherlich nicht irgendwie Jahre laufend eher auf Wochen oder auf Monate bezogen.
Aber man weiß das nicht. Man weiß nicht, wann diese Stichtage dann letzten Endes sind.
So Kontakten monatelang oder so was.
Ah okay, also okay, also das heißt, wenn wenn man weiß, dass das ist, kann man davon ausgehen, dass es so in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten üblicherweise
stattfinden wird, dass das sozusagen ist. So, jetzt kam die Reddit-Community und da hat sich irgendwie die Hände gerieben, hat gesagt, den denen zeigen was. Wir kaufen jetzt Gamestop-Aktien. Richtig?
Und das haben sie dann auch getan. Das hat er dann zur Folge, aus äh erstmal, weil das generell so ist, wenn große Nachfrage ist, dass der Kurs nach oben geht, aber auch wahrscheinlich, weil dann eben dieser, dieser Kaufbedarf, dieser Schorzeller dann auch mit eingesetzt hat und dann ging der Preis immer weiter hoch.
Der hat sich dann jetzt von zwanzig Dollar auf dreihundertfünfzig Dollar erhöht.
Bis zu fünfhundert Dollar im Tagesverlauf.
Okay, also so Faktor siebzehn, achtzehn und was hat das jetzt für.
Auswirkungen gehabt, von dem man jetzt weiß, also gibt's jetzt schon konkrete Hedgefonds, die so richtig in Probleme gelaufen sind oder ist steht das jetzt noch unmittelbar bevor?
Das ist, was ich gerade sage, dieser Melvin Hedgefond, der über Nacht vier Milliarden verloren hat und fast pleite war, das ist das bekannteste Beispiel, der jetzt dann vom Kollegen gerettet wurde und sicherlich werden da auch noch einige sein, die von dem man nichts weiß, beziehungsweise in den nächsten Tagen oder Wochen noch sicherlich was nachkommen.
Okay, also es ist sozusagen, kann kann sich in den nächsten Wochen noch verstärken, dass es noch weitere Meldungen gibt, dass jetzt Hedgefonds in Problemen laufen. Was könnte denn jetzt hier maximal Probier äh passieren deiner Meinung nach?
Deswegen ist ja, dass es ja weitere Kreise zieht. Also es gibt ja jetzt zum Beispiel in den USA eine eine Trading äh App äh Robin Hood. Ähm,
die jetzt ja zum Beispiel auch über Nacht jetzt auch gestern gesagt haben, dass gewisse Aktien unter anderem auch eine Gamestop als Beispiel vom Handel ausgeschlossen sind,
So, warum passiert das natürlich? Weil ich auf einer ähm Robin Hood-Plattform,
sage mal fünftausend Euro Einzahl, aber Games top Aktien im Gegenwert von zehntausend Euro handeln kann. Also gehebelt.
So, ist natürlich doof, weil diese Robin Hood, diese diese App oder die, das Finanzinstitut dahinter, muss natürlich auch entsprechend Sicherheitsgeld hinterlegen.
Aktie natürlich relativ volatil ist, dann ist natürlich die Frage, wenn es ich die Aktie irgendwie, weiß ich, bei ähm hundert kaufen, es steht morgen bei dreihundert, ist halt die Frage, ob sie die nächsten fünf Minuten immer noch da steht,
Das heißt, ihr kommt natürlich in große Schwierigkeiten, diese Sicherheiten dar.
In der Form zu hinterlegen. So, das heißt, die kollabieren natürlich in der Form. Wir haben jetzt zum Beispiel vor zwei Tagen nochmal eine Milliarde Kapitalerhöhung gemacht, weil sie nicht mehr nur noch Sicherheiten hatten entsprechend.
Kannst du kurz Exkurs, wie man gehebelt investiert, ich möchte auch mehr investieren als ich habe. Vor allem im Games.
Oh Gott.
Naja, also sagen wir mal, gehen wir durch diesen Konserce-Fall, du hast als Beispiel einen einen Aktiendepot, darin befindet sich in den SAP und eine Siemens-Aktie und das hat einen Gegenwert von zehntausend Euro,
kannst du eigentlich im Schnitt bei so 'ner Consorsbank als Beispiel zum dreißig Prozent Wertpapierkredit aufnehmen kannst mit dem Geld weiter handeln? Das ist so, ich sage mal die einfachste Form.
Kannst natürlich auch so was wie Robin Hood nehmen.
Schätzen die, die dein Risiko irgendwo ein und je nachdem wie viel Geld auch du eingezahlt hast und da kannst du jederzeit geäbelt handeln logischerweise,
und die verdienen natürlich an so einem Ankauf und Verkaufspreis, da schlagen die ein bisschen was drauf, so dass die natürlich dann auch auf ihre Marge kommen.
Das kannst du eigentlich machen, wie du lustig bist, natürlich, wenn du deinem Verlust gerätst, muss natürlich auch relativ zügig irgendwie eindecken, damit die natürlich nicht auf ihrem Verlust da eben sitzen bleiben.
Also Prinzip kann das jeder.
Okay, ist das, also es klingt mir alles nicht so ratsam, irgendwie so zu sagen, willst du einen Kredit auf deine Aktien nehmen? Ist so, hm.
Solange alles nach oben geht, ist ja alles gut. Wenn deine Siemens und SAP fällt, klar, dann sagt auch die Contest Bank. So, ähm jetzt schießt doch mal ein bisschen Geld nach und wenn du das Geld natürlich nicht hast, hast du natürlich ein Problem.
Wenn ich das hätte, dann brauche ich ja keinen Kredit aufzunehmen.
Was passiert denn jetzt mit diesen ganzen redit Investoren, die jetzt diese Gamestop-Aktien gekauft haben und was hat das auch für Auswirkungen für Gamestop,
Wenn die hier jetzt klug waren, haben sie ja dann irgendwie eine eine Kapitalerhöhung gemacht, sind sozusagen jetzt eh die die Aktien knapp sind, könnten sie ja dann äh sich jetzt mit diesem hohen Kurs äh richtig schön äh refinanzieren.
Ja, das haben sie bisher noch nicht getan. Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob überhaupt jemand so eine Kapitalerhöhung bezeichnen wird,
glaube, bei Tesla ist natürlich einfach klar, da gibt's dann auch Leute, an die das Geschäftsmodell glauben, jetzt weiß ich nicht, ob das irgendwie so eine Gamestop irgendwie ähm hinbekommen würde, wenn du im im maximalen ähm äh Rahmen sicherlich.
Das heißt, wenn wenn die so eine so einen Verkauf machen, dann muss der sozusagen auch als Kapitalerhöhung explizit deklariert werden. Ist nicht so, dass einfach die Aktien auf den Markt schmeißt und da jetzt eh gerade alle kaufen, gehen die dann auch mit weg.
Nein, du hast ja, ich sage mal, jedes Jahr durch deinen Aufsichtsrat genehmigt ein kleines Polster, was du dir ein neues Kapital beschaffen darfst, wenn du mehr haben willst, muss natürlich eine außerordentliche Sammelsitzung einberufen oder bei der nächsten Hauptversammlung,
du gehst natürlich dann als eine Gamescom zu einer Investmentbank, weiß ich Goldman Sachs, Morgan Stanley und sagst, Leute, ich möchte gerne hier mehr Aktien ausgeben. Ähm bitte platziert doch das entsprechend. Die rufen dann ihre Kunden an oder ähm im.
Weiß nicht, worth the Best Case gibt's das nicht oder du holst es dir am Alter im Aktienmarkt halt direkt. Das ist aber eine der übliche Vorgang.
Verstehe. Also die Religioser, die jetzt einfach sich irgendwelche Aktien auf Börsen äh klicken würden, dann sozusagen da nicht automatisch äh zuschlagen.
Nee, wahrscheinlich nicht. Weil's einfach Privatkunden sind in der Form,
Ich meine, spannend ist, wenn man sich in diesem Forum mal irgendwie rumtreibt, ist eigentlich so eher so die Kommunikationsstruktur und das das gesellschaftliche Phänomen finde ich dahinter.
Also ich habe Kommentare gelesen, die hießen demnach, ähm so, ich kaufe jetzt Gamestop-Aktien, ist mir vollkommen egal, ob ich da pleite dabei pleite gehe. Hauptsache, ich trete diesen Hedgefond-Leuten halt in den Hintern. Also ist, glaube ich, schon eher so eine gewisse Ideologie schon einfach dahinter,
es gab teilweise Kommentare, wo Leute sagten, meine Eltern sind zweitausendacht in der Finanzkrise pleite gegangen, jeder wurde gerettet, nur meine Eltern heiratet eben nicht und ich möchte jetzt gegen dieses System halt irgendwie antreten. Also ist ja, einfach eine neue Form des Protestes, würde ich einfach sagen.
Ja. Und auch durchaus äh effizient, also wie sehr gut, Melvin, hat jetzt Probleme gehabt. Was denkst du, wie groß ist jetzt der Schaden, der dieser Finanzindustrie da insgesamt äh entstehen kann oder diesen Hedgefonds konkret?
Letztes Jahr bei vierzig Milliarden war, dann wird das bei einer Gamescom wahrscheinlich irgendwie im ähnlichen Rahmen irgendwie ablaufen.
Und wie wie wehtut denen das?
Wenn so eine Melvin Capital, sagen wir mal, zwölf Komma fünf Milliarden verwaltet und jetzt schon dreißig Prozent verloren haben, so dann tut ihnen das natürlich arg weh, zumal auch sicherlich, dass so eine Kaskade sein kann, dass der Kunde sagt, sag mal, Leute, die sehen doch alle, wir ziehen unser Geld halt ab. Das heißt, so ein Laden kann natürlich von heute auf morgen auch entsprechend seine Pforten schließen.
Und wird das diesem ganzen Ökosystem irgendwie dann auch einen dauerhaften Schaden beifügen oder gehen jetzt nur ein paar Player pleite?
Es gab ja mal in den neunziger Jahren den Fall da gab's ein der tatsächlich auch Position hat das ganze Finanzsystem ins Wanken gebracht hat und ich glaube das ist auch die die Gefahr dabei was jetzt zu Finanzaufsichten halt irgendwie sehen weil natürlich das was jetzt.
Irgendwo durch die Gegend fliegt, natürlich so ein ganzes System einfach ins Wanken bringt, weil's einfach nicht natürlich ist,
und ich glaube, das ist die große Gefahr dabei, ähm dass man sich jetzt da was auslöst, was man eigentlich nicht haben möchte. Ähm,
Ja, jetzt müssen wir aber schauen, ob man das in dieser Form alle wieder beruhigen kann. Also noch sieht es irgendwie alles harmlos aus, aber kann natürlich auch größere Effekte haben. Zumal es ja auch einfach mehr Unternehmen mit reinzieht. Wir reden jetzt hier nur über Gamesstop,
gerade gesagt, eine AMC, eine Blackberry, Großkopfhörer oder wer auch immer da noch betroffen ist, die sind ja genauso gestiegen, vielleicht nicht zweihundert Prozent am Tag, sondern halt fünfzig Prozent.
Tatsächlich ist es so, ich habe eine Firma bei mir im im Portfolio am Montag. Ich äh die Börse begann und äh die Aktie machte auch plus neunundzwanzig Prozent. Das ist ähm Evotec aus Hamburg, ist ein biotech Unternehmen. Auch da waren äh ja Hedge Force Short gewesen schon, aber schon seit Jahren eigentlich.
Die Aktie ist natürlich dabei am Ende bei Plus vier Prozent geschlossen,
man da mal den Vorstand von der Firma fragt sprecht ihr eigentlich mit den was sind die Argumente? Dann sprechen die vielleicht mit fünf Prozent dieser Hedgefonds. Der Rest meldet sich gar nicht,
die haben natürlich dann gewisse Argumente. Mir leuchten die in diesem Fall nicht ein, aber okay, jeder hat ja seine freie Meinung, kann sich dann da irgendwie machen, was er halt möchte.
Sei es Gamescom ist jetzt eigentlich nur das sichtbarste Opfer gewesen ist oder oder der sichtbarste Anlass gewesen, sagen wir's mal so, die sind ja nicht im eigentlichen Sinne jetzt die,
Opfer an dieser Stelle. Äh aber es gab noch ein paar andere Unternehmen, wo das auch getan wurde
und könnte ja durchaus sein, dass die jetzt quasi in ihrem Rausch sagen, jetzt jetzt äh zerlegen wir die komplette Hedgefront in Industrie und jedes Unternehmen, was hier irgendwie so halbwegs äh im äh Anstieg ist, wird jetzt hier einfach hochgezogen.
Na das geht ja nur, wenn das genug Leute geschottet haben. Also ich würde, Entschuldigung, Daniel, wenn ich da mal als Laie versuche zu antworten, ähm dass also.
Kurz nochmal die Begriffe, also es gibt shorten, es gibt da diese Quote wie stark das Unternehmen geschortet ist und das war Gamestop war halt einfach so der Prügelknabe,
dieser Shortzeller. Die haben einfach immer gesagt, ein bisschen war noch die prügeln wir einfach nach unten, ne? Und weil wenn es einfach genug machen, denken alle, ja, geil, machen wir auch mit,
Und dann passiert aber irgendwann kippt das, dass du halt so einen da drauf hast, dass es angreifbar wird,
Und diese dieses Angreifen, nämlich zu sagen, alles klar, wir kaufen jetzt diese Aktien, die sind ja billig und wir verkaufen die nicht.
Egal was wie die steigen ne? Also wir machen den Markt für diese Aktie einfach,
und weil wir wissen, dass wir eine gesicherte Nachfrage haben. Das nennt man Short Squeeze. Also wir wir quetschen, dass diese ganzen geschorteten aus, weil wir wissen, die brauchen diese Aktie. Und wir geben die denen einfach nicht.
Das funktioniert natürlich auch nur in den USA, weil dort ist relativ viele Optionen, auch viele Unternehmen gibt, A und B ist natürlich Gamestop auch grundsätzlich nicht so liquide, was die Aktien angeht, also ein Tesla ist ja viel liquider als so eine Gamestop. Das heißt, je enger so ein Titel ist, desto einfacher geht das natürlich auch.
Und jetzt passiert dadurch schießt natürlich der Kurs jetzt hoch.
Alles sitzen auf der Aktie und haben im Prinzip jetzt grade einen äh den gleichen äh äh Konflikt, den alle haben, wenn eine Aktie steigt, sozusagen so okay, wann wann steige ich aus?
Die sitzen da jetzt einfach alle und sagen, okay, Hodel, Hodel, Hode, ich bin hier der äh ich mache jetzt hier den diese ganzen Hedgefonds kaputt,
Und da gab es jetzt auch schon Meldungen, dass teilweise diese äh Trading Plattform,
den Leuten, die Aktien zwangsverkauft haben. Da bin ich mir aber nicht sicher, das wurde von Robin Hood behauptet, aber wiederum auf, also über Robin Hood behauptet, aber von Robin Hood dementiert, aber Leute haben irgendwie so,
Screenshots gezeigt, wo Robin Hood quasi sagt, nee, wir haben die jetzt verkauft für dich, um dich vor weiteren Verlusten zu beschützen, weil.
Auf jeden Fall ist das, was mit Gamestop gerade passiert, ein sogenannter Pump and Dump. Was heißt, diese Gamestop aktiviert in,
relativ nahe Zukunft wieder komplett da unten sein, wo sie hingehört,
Ja, das wird vielleicht zwanzig Dollar sein oder vierzig, das kann Daniel mir vielleicht besser sagen, aber die wird nicht, die wird diesen hohen Kurs nicht halten können, weil der hohe Kurs kommt nur daher, dass gerade diese gezwungen sind, die zu kaufen. Und dieser Spuk ist bald vorbei.
Weil natürlich keiner mehr Games Topf gerade.
Das ist natürlich die Aktie Zwangseingedeckt wirst, klar, passiert natürlich auf jeden Fall, nämlich dann, wenn ich gehebelter agiere und ich nicht mehr genug Kapital habe, um äh natürlich Sicherheiten zu stellen, dann sagt natürlich Robin Hut irgendwann mal, ey Moment mal, ähm hier, wir stellen das Ding platt,
decken das ganze Ding ein. Klar passiert das. Aber das,
vor ein paar Tagen wieder drin hast und die waren dich vorher vor und sofort nicht komplett automatisch. Also der hat sicherlich eine E-Mail bekommen.
Und wenn du da jetzt quasi sitzt und hast jetzt irgendwie diese Gamestop-Aktien, dann heißt das für dich okay, A ich kann äh also ich habe jetzt äh zwei Optionen, ich halte die.
Oder ich verkaufe sie irgendwann um die Gewinne zu realisieren,
Das wird ja sicherlich auch passieren, also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass da jetzt nicht Leute sagen, alles klar, ich ich sehe jetzt mal zu, dass ich Teile dieser Gewinne,
irgendwie realisiere und irgendwann gibt's keine Nachfrage mehr danach und die Hedgefonds gehen pleite oder sonst was und dann dann fällt die Aktie wieder in sich zusammen.
Und zwischendurch sind ein paar Hedge vor uns pleite gegangen. Eigentlich äh Gewinner auf allen Seiten.
Also sie hätte vor uns äh haben auf jeden Fall bitter zahlen müssen. Die User, die sich an dieser ganzen Geschichte beteiligt haben, haben am Ende auch,
Kursgewinne erzielt und konnten die dann auch realisieren.
Das ist ja wirklich ein sehr einträglicher Protest. Also es ist ja selten, dass man jetzt bei bei einer Demonstration gegen das internationale kapitalistische System auch noch dafür bezahlt wird.
Stimmt.
Würde sagen, es ist eine der erfolgreichsten äh Umverteilungsmaßnahmen von von oben nach unten.
Die Kommunisten haben Geschäftsmodell. Geil. Ja.
Organisiert. Jetzt muss man sagen, das sind ja keine Kommunisten, die in diesem Wall Street Bats rumhängen, sondern ähm also die versuchen ja die ganze Zeit solche Scherze, ne, dass sie sich absprechen und das äh.
Weiß ja genauso im letzten Jahr, ne? Also ist ja, ist jetzt nicht mehr so hochgepoppt bei GameStop, also das passiert ja regelmäßig.
Bei der nächsten Demo der Schwarze Block fährt jetzt Tesla. Ja. Weil die Kohle, die kommt ja rein, ne?
Ich finde, ich finde diese Dynamik irgendwie ganz spannend. Ich habe mal ähm vor vier, fünf Jahren mal mit äh ist einer der Gründer von PayPal ähm äh Abend gegessen, hatte damals in der Firma neu gegründet, A Form,
so ein bisschen was vielleicht die meisten in Deutschland kennen, als Klana, also ein Portal, ähm wenn ich jetzt im Adidas-Tor gehe und möchte irgendwie eine Hose kaufen und kann es mir nicht leisten, ähm dass ich's in Raten zahlen kann, aber eben nicht als
Kredit in der Form, dass ich noch on top was zahle, sondern es wird dem Adidas aufgebürgt, ähm das Erde und auch die Kosten dahinter bezahlen muss.
Und ähm das habe ich mich gefragt, warum machen die Leute das? Ähm und das mal vorwiegend tatsächlich mit Daniels, in USA auch keine Kreditkarten mehr haben, weil sie sagen, wir mögen das Finanzsystem nicht, gerade irgendwie wo Kredite damals weiter verkauft wurden und somit ist sein Geschäftsmodell entstanden.
Das finde ich irgendwie ganz spannend, insbesondere wenn man sieht, dass man in den USA äh Millennials und Genzi ungefähr fünfundneunzig Millionen ausmachen, die jedes Jahr um fünf Millionen dazu kommen. Das heißt, wir haben ja irgendwann mal auch eine Form, wo, sagen wir mal, in Millenniums die größte Kaufgruppe halt ist,
Das ist halt die Frage, wo sich sowas halt in der Zukunft hinbewegen kann, welche Protestform halt es eben noch gibt,
weil man zumindest auf diese ganzen alten Strukturen, diese jungen Leute eben sprechen, keine Lust mehr haben, beziehungsweise ich verarscht einfach fühlen und teilweise auch zurecht.
Ja, das ist also okay,
Jetzt habe ich gesehen, was ich also was ich sehr schön finde, sind so Meldungen wie, ey, das ist wirklich das ist gefährlich, was diese Reda da machen, die ähm,
erschüttern ja das Vertrauen in den Aktienhandel, wo du denkst so,
sorry, nee, also äh diese also es ist ja, es ist ja nicht so, als hätten die irgendwas neu erfunden, sondern alles, was die da machen, da gibt's ja schon Wörter für.
Ne Short Squeeze.
Pump and Dummys, der dieses Skalping, genau, das ist ja auch ähm ist ja eine eine Form der Marktmonipation, das ist natürlich logischerweise verboten,
Wenn ich das mir meinen irgendwelchen anderen Fonds Kollegen zusammen machen würde, was auch zu neuen Marktzeiten gab, wo man sich gegenseitig Aktien hochkauft, natürlich, es ist hochgradig verboten, dafür kommst du natürlich ins Gefängnis,
Wie gesagt, ist natürlich schwierig, dass einem Radio nachzuweisen, wenn er schreibt hier, ich finde Gamestop.
Ja, es gibt allerdings auch äh also ich sehe hier einen Post grade auf äh Wallstreet Batsvell sagt ähm hört auf, darüber zu kommentieren oder zu zu posten, dass dass man sich hier organisiert hätte.
Weil die SEC, also äh die,
Die BAFÖN der USA äh sonst natürlich hier dieses äh Subradit äh schließen wird, per Dekret, weil das eben eine illegale Taktik ist, aber du kannst mir nicht erzählen, also ich meine, diese ganze Sachen funktionieren doch,
primär darüber, dass Leute sich absprechen.
Primär darüber, dass der und kündigt das an und es steht überall und dann sagen alle, oh geil, da shoppen wir mal mit oder so. Oder wir verkaufen jetzt. Also dass dass das alles mit.
Wenn nicht explizit dann aber zumindest impliziter Organisation zu tun hat, äh lässt sich doch echt nicht ähm.
Doch echt nicht bestreiten, oder?
Aber das Ding ist natürlich, wenn ich jetzt das Reddit Forum dort schließe, ja, okay, kann man machen, aber genauso schuld eine Situation oder ist ja auch deine Hedgefond. Also, ich meine, wo fange ich da an?
Das heißt, im Grunde genommen wird ja dann schon wieder die Finanzindustrie gerettet und ähm alles wird für schön und gut erklärt, damit die weitermachen können und dann wird wieder ein ganz anderer Abend des Protestes entsprechend geschlossen.
Also wenn müsste ich hier beides schließen oder zumindest beschneiden.
Ja
Also dann mal, wie, wie geht diese Sache jetzt weiter? Also ihr, was wäre jetzt so das ist ja nicht das erste Mal, dass das passiert. Man muss ja jetzt nicht auf,
auf Daten genau sagen so äh was glaubst du wird passieren? Vor allem blicke ich da mit der Frage auf diese äh hundertzwanzig Prozent geschortet, was ja so ein bisschen darauf deutet, dass das,
sich eventuell nicht auflösen lässt. Du hast das ja gerade schon gesagt, dass die also theoretisch ließe es sich auflösen, wenn's alle an einem Tag machen. Das werden die aber nicht tun.
Ja, das ist eine spannende Frage. Ich meine, also diese ganze Geschichte mit Short Selling und dagegen halten, das wird sicherlich in der Form weiter äh ähm wird sicherlich irgendwie weitergehen. Wie gesagt, das haben wir schon seit Jahren. Das ist ja in dem Maße nichts Neues. Das ist der Dennis wird maßgeblich irgendetwas verboten, was ich jetzt kurzfristig auf jeden Fall nicht sehe.
So in diesem Gamestop-Ding ist natürlich die Frage, wer hält da wo wie am längsten durch? Ich glaube, das ist einfach das Spiel, was man jetzt dabei hat,
ich gehe eigentlich mal ganz stark davon aus, dass die meisten Hedgeforce auch entsprechend ihre Position schon glatt gestellt haben, weil ich glaube nicht, dass sie jetzt noch so hohe Risiken in ihren Büchern einfach haben,
natürlich jetzt passiert ist, dass jetzt irgendwelche Daytrader vielleicht sogar auf den, auf den Plan kommen, die ähm sagen, oh, ist eine hohe Voltilität, da kann ich natürlich jetzt bei mir mitmachen. Ich sehe, die Aktie ist bei sechzig,
sicherlich hochgekauft und verkauft sie wieder bei hundert, das passiert wahrscheinlich jetzt gerade noch, was den Kurs treibt.
Diese hundertzwanzig Prozent, wie gesagt, ist jetzt Stand der Dinge auf einem Stichtag bezogen, aber in Wirklichkeit kann's eigentlich schon ganz anders aussehen. Ich glaube, dass sich das einfach über die nächsten Wochen einfach auslaufen wird.
Auslaufen heißt, die Aktie landet wieder irgendwo.
Wo sie hingehört, ja. Oder vielleicht hingehört.
Äh die die Leute, die mit der blauen Nase werden, im Zweifelsfall wahrscheinlich nur diejenigen sein, die dick geschortet haben.
Weil du ja gesagt hast, die Aktie war ohnehin an der Welluit mit anderen Worten, selbst wenn ich jetzt äh das Spiel mitgespielt habe bei was weiß ich, Aktienkurs von fünf oder zehn Dollar. Da drunter wird sie potenziell nicht fallen,
langfristig.
Ich meine, derjenige, der die These vertreten hat, da ist noch Werten, der bei fünf Dollar eingestiegen ist. Sonst net immer die Frage des Timings. Also, ich kann mir jetzt nicht vorstellen, dass der wartet, bis die Aktie bei dreihundertfünfzig ist. Der wird sie sicherlich scheinen wie vorher bei fünfzig oder sonst wo verkauft haben.
Anders kann ich mir das hier nicht vorstellen, sonst macht die Rechnung ja auch irgendwie keinen Sinn. Der ist auch schon längst draußen. So, die Aktie wird natürlich dann sicherlich da hinfallen, wo sie herkamen, vielleicht irgendwie auf die zwanzig zurück.
So und da muss man jetzt irgendwie sehen, derjenige, der da eingestiegen ist und jetzt der die zwölf Prozent hält, ob jetzt wirklich daraus das Geschäftsmodell in die Zukunft führen kann und ein E-Commerceportal rausmacht, was dann irgendwie sehr erfolgreich irgendwie ähm äh ist.
Vorstellen kann ich mir das nicht, aber wer weiß das schon?
Aber ich meine, die Lehre aus diesem ganzen Spiel ist natürlich irgendwie eins, alle, die glauben, dass sie schnell reich werden, das geht nunmal nicht, das was über das, was wir jetzt gerade hier eben reden, dass es sich einmal wichtig, festzuhalten ist, ähm äh Casino. Also wir können auch auf Schwarz oder Rot wetten, das ist genau das gleiche Spiel.
Das, was wir haben, ist, ist zocken und das andere, was viel wichtiger ist, ist es investieren und das ist dann das, was ihr den Fondsmanager macht, wie ich, und da geht's dann eher um langfristige Dinge.
Wenn, also welche Informationen, wenn ich jetzt Gamestop-Aktien hätte, ja, welche,
Informationen werden mir denn zugänglich, um zu
gucken, wann ich die richtige Entscheidung treffe. Kann ich zum Beispiel sehen, wie viele Gamestop-Aktien gerade verkauft werden, um zu wissen, okay, noch hodeln alle, also hodel ich mit? Oder kann ich sagen, ähm,
Ich habe eigentlich immer nur den Preis da und ich habe äh ich würde jetzt also wahrscheinlich würde ich ja nicht alle auf einmal abgeben, sondern versuchen meine Gewinne nacheinander so ein bisschen zu realisieren.
Gibt's da welche Informationen haben die denn, worauf sie jetzt gucken könnten?
Du siehst natürlich jeden Tag das Volumen, was umgeht und das auch sowohl auf der Kauf- als auch der ähm der ähm Verkaufsseite. Gut, natürlich am Tagesumspiel, ne? Es muss ja am Tag genauso viele Käufer und Verkäufer ähm geben. Ich sehe natürlich das Volumen auf jeden Fall. Ähm.
Ich habe natürlich eine eine eine Schwankungsbreite, dann sehe ich natürlich noch, wie nervös äh die Anleger in so einer Aktie sind. So dauernd kann man sich dran festhalten, aber ich glaube, sicherlich klar, in dem steht auch Leute, die sagen, sie wollen die Aktie irgendwie auf tausend bringen. Also für unmöglich halte ich's jetzt wahrscheinlich irgendwie nicht,
Aber wie gesagt, das wäre einfach maximales Wetten darauf, dass wenn du sie bei dreihundert gekauft hast, dass sie vielleicht jemals da bei tausend rauskommt, also ist wie im Kasino auf rot setzen. Ich glaube, mehr Anhaltspunkte hast du da auch gar nicht.
Na ja, auf Rot finde ich sie also ich habe ja, wenn ich die jetzt kaufe, habe ich ja zumindest jeden Tag die Möglichkeit, sie zu verkaufen. Also bei schwarz oder rot habe ich ja nur eins oder null. Ich habe ja hier schon so ein bisschen ähm.
Also ich kann ja zumindest überlegen, wann ich wann ich verkaufe.
Genau, hier reden wir aber von Timing und Timing, ja, ist halt sehr, sehr schwer. Gibt, glaube ich, nur wenig Leute, die Timing beherrschen. Oder wie Buffet mal gesagt hat, er hat noch nie in der Top Ten der erfolgreichsten Anleger jemanden gesehen, der nur durch Timing reich geworden ist.
Hm, hm.
Tja, musst du deine Skills noch ein bisschen holen irgendwie? Bevor du hier in dem ins Millionärspublikum äh aufsteigst. Mal gucken, ob du auf dieser komischen Webseite auch schon als Millionär gefühlt bist.
Ich glaube, man muss, also man muss natürlich noch eine Sache dazu sagen,
Ich hab ja also das wird ja jetzt so 'n bisschen also einerseits auf ein kleines bisschen natürlich zu Recht als irgendwie so 'n David gegen Goliath, ne? Reddit, Kleinanleger, ähm versus äh,
äh
Ich hab's jetzt ja gerade auch eine schöne Umverteilungsmaßnahme von oben nach unten genannt. Dabei bleibe ich auch. Es heißt natürlich nicht, dass hier nicht auch inzwischen entsprechende Trader längst mitspielen, ne? Also da gibt's sicherlich auch,
in diesem Redit äh sicherlich auch einige Leute, die.
Ja, das Potential dieses da gesehen haben und da vielleicht auch seit längerem mitspielen und jetzt natürlich immer versuchen, durch Täuschung irgendeinen Wissensvorteil gegenüber anderen äh zu haben, um in dem Spiel mitzumachen. Deswegen.
Mein Gefühl an der Sache war, okay, wenn ich jetzt nicht wirklich den ganzen Tag auf diesen scheiß Kurs gucken will äh und nicht mehr schlafen kann, weil ich Angst haben muss, dass zwischendurch auf einmal Gamestop abrauscht. Ähm dann lasse ich da lieber einfach die Finger von.
Ich meine, mittlerweile gibt's ja auch Algorithmen, weiß nicht, ob sowas auf redet Foren schon funktioniert, aber auf Twitter auf jeden Fall, weil natürlich auch dann mit einer KI und entsprechenden Daten abschnorcheln, natürlich auch so was einfach schon ausgewertet wird. Also, würde mich nicht wundern, wenn auch schon ein Hedgefond genau so was macht mit irgendwelchen Textnachrichten in diesen Foren halt mit Sicherheit.
Übrigens wunderschön, da hatten wir auch, ich glaube, das war, äh kam über Twitter, der Kommentar zu uns, der Signal Hype.
Signal wird ja betrieben von einer von also von einer Firma, die im Prinzip das macht für einen Non-Profit
Ja, es ist so ein Konstrukt, um quasi einerseits als Unternehmen agieren zu können, andererseits vollständig nur ein Profit zu sein
Und äh der Hype von Signal hat auch dazu geführt, dass irgendein Unternehmen, was irgendwie Signal Industries heißt und irgendwie was weiß ich, Zahnpastatuben herstellt oder sowas, ja. Ähm.
Dass die irgendwie auch Kurssteigerungen im im zweistelligen Prozentbereich hatten, einfach nur, weil irgendwelche dämlichen ähm,
ja wahrscheinlich Autotrading, Algorithmen gesagt haben geiles Ding hier da hören wir viel positives drüber rein. Und das ist schon wirklich enorm irre was was man in diesem Bereich,
mit den also durch digitale Phänomene jetzt hat, ne.
Es gibt eine Webseite, die heißt Down Detektor. Da kann ich mir die ganzen Dienste anschauen, also klar angefangen bei Google, Twitter, aber auch bei REDDIT, ähm wann sie denn down sind und das auch nochmal auf so einer Heatmap abgetragen. Also ich kann täglich nur auf solchen Landkarten eigentlich auch sehen, wo kommen diese ganzen Trade halt her?
Also bei Red hatte ich mal gesehen, zu diesen Hochzeiten, wenn die fast mal down waren. Ein Großteil war so um Dallas zum Beispiel angesiedelt. Warum auch immer, kann ich nicht erklären, aber das ist natürlich auch irgendwie ganz, ganz interessant, zumindest die Daten aber irgendwie
sich genau anzugucken.
Mit Down meinst du jetzt, dass die.
Der Serverzugriff natürlich so immens war, dass die Seite irgendwie dann für eine kurze Zeit vielleicht nicht erreichbar war.
Okay. Oh je.
Gab's gab's ja auch mal bei, ich glaube, für eine Stunde war doch, glaube ich, noch vor ein paar Tagen sogar, dass das Forum mal irgendwie komplett geschlossen gewesen.
Weil die Radid äh ähm Community gesagt hat, wir waren nicht mehr in der Lage entsprechend jetzt die Posts irgendwie zu kontrollieren und dann waren wir uns nicht sicher, dass wir nicht was vielleicht Nachrichten landeten, die da nicht hinsollten und da haben sie's für eine Stunde geschlossen.
Ja, auf jeden Fall äh das Ansehen der Börse steht auf dem Spiel,
Also haut drauf, haut drauf Leute. Das ist wirklich äh ja, ich find's wirklich ähm also ich habe an dieser Sache meine,
Meine Freude bin ich ganz ehrlich und aber gleichzeitig ist es also denke man muss auf jeden Fall nochmal festhalten, das ist etwas, was eigentlich vielleicht nicht in diesem Ausmaß, aber eigentlich ganz alltäglich ist, unter diesen Zockerleuten, oder?
Exakt.
Das ist ja der Grund, warum Tesla so immens gestiegen ist. Das ist auch der Grund, warum Elon Musk so sehr gegen jetzt äh wettet, weil natürlich er genau diese Radit-Leute, ja, gehabt hat, die ihm natürlich auch geholfen haben, diesen Kurs dann nach oben zu treiben.
Und natürlich darf man übrigens auch nicht vergessen, ähm dass natürlich auch so ein Phänomen aus der Coronazeit ähm sag mal.
Sieht's natürlich aus relativ viele Leute, sowohl in Europa, aber auch in USA natürlich zu Hause, die irgendwelche Staatshilfen bekommen haben und nicht wissen, was sie mit ihrem Geld machen,
Also ich bekomme tagtäglich Fragen von Privatleuten, von Freunden, Bekannten, die sagen, wie mache ich mein Bitcoin-Konto auf, ähm wo kann ich irgendwie Aktien kaufen, die jetzt irgendwo Geld herbekommen haben? Und jetzt Langeweile haben anfangen zu zocken.
So und das ist natürlich auch so ein Phänomen aus dieser ganzen Blase halt heraus.
Glaubst du, dass das äh in ein Ausmaß jetzt geht, weil wir haben ja jetzt viel über Gamescom geredet, aber du hast auch immer wieder gesagt, dass andere ähm
Unternehmen betroffen sind. Ich habe jetzt auch gesehen, Dorschcoin ist auch irgendwie hochgeschossen. Ähm die spielen diese Spiele jetzt.
Das hat mediale Aufmerksamkeit und das hat natürlich durchaus theoretisch das Potential ähm.
Ja, dass das jetzt rund geht, ne, dass das dass die das weitermachen, dass die dass also dass das, dass das bei Gamestop funktioniert, dann wird's irgendwelche äh äh YouTube-Beiträge oder Clubhaus-Chats über Leute geben, die sagen,
Ich habe mir jetzt einen Ferrari gekauft, Gamestop heißt das Ding. Als nächstes nehmen wir äh nehmen wir was weiß ich diese Aktie hier. Und ähm,
sich das, dass es halt hyped, also ich sehe das ja auch mit mit Unwohlsein.
Regelmäßig zum Beispiel im Bereich Bitcoin, äh bei bei unterschiedlichen Aktien, dass solche Hypes passieren, ja? Jetzt irgendwie ähm in letzter Zeit häufen sich Leute, die wenig Ahnung von.
Finanzmärkten oder Blockchains haben,
Aber irgendwelche, in irgendwelchen Klapphaus-Chats, irgendwelche fantastischen Ideen haben von Smart Contracts und so und dann in irgendwelche Kryptowährungen einsteigen und dann natürlich auch erstmal irre Wachstumsraten,
realisieren, weil das halt auch einfach Ponziskims sind, die weitergehen. Und solange man den Leuten sagt, yo, yo, hodel, hodel, hodel, ist ja auch klar, dass ähm.
Dass die Kurse steigen, aber dem gibt's eben diese Gegenbewegung, dass irgendwann, dass irgendwann alle wissen, so, das ist nun mal hier ein Pyramidenspiel und wenn ich die Gewinne realisieren will, dann muss ich das zumindest irgendwann auch mal machen,
und wenn das, also da das jetzt immer mehr Leute machen und immer mehr unbedarfte Leute machen, ähm,
könnte es natürlich schon durchaus sein, dass diese Geschichte am Ende doch damit endet, dass die dass die kleinen Leute hier ähm die Verluste wieder einstreichen, während die Großen sagen.
Ja, wir streichen jetzt hier mal Verluste ein. Wir kennen aber dieses Spiel, mal gewinnste, mal verlieren die anderen, aber normalerweise machen wir im Jahr dreißig Prozent Rendite und das machen wir nächstes Jahr auch wieder.
Du siehst ja auch, wenn die Motivation der Leute schon irgendwie ist, mir ist egal, ob ich alles verliere, Hauptsache ich trete in dem Hintern, ist ja sogar das, was schon einprogrammiert hat, ne? Und dann geht's ja sogar schon eine ebene Höhe schon höher sozusagen. Da geht's ja gar nicht mehr um Gewinne, sondern dann geht's um eine ganz andere Ebene halt.
Ich würde einen solchen Kommentar, ehrlich gesagt, ich also man hört das viel, aber das halte ich für ähm ja, ehrlich gesagt.
Einzelfall.
Oder auch ehrlich gesagt.
Also für sich das selber schönreden, dass man gerade äh irgendwie eine hundert im im hunderte Prozentbereich Gewinne einfährt,
und zweitens andere dazu motivieren weiterhin sich ja nicht risikobewußt zu verhalten, weil das natürlich dem eigenen,
den den eigenen Gewinnsteigerung auch dienlich ist.
Also ich glaube, ehrlich gesagt nicht, dass da wirklich Menschen sitzen und sagen, yo, geil, ich meine Eltern sind schon an der Börse pleite gegangen. Jetzt gehe ich auch pleite. Nur damit diese
ein paar Verluste einstreichen. Das kann, das würde ich auch irgendwie,
Selbstwert dienlich im kleinen Kreis erzählen, vor allem wenn ich dann irgendwie mit meinem Tesla vorfahre
um äh und und und äh und teure Zigarren rauche oder so und dann sagen so, nee, nee, Leute, ich habe das nur gemacht aus aus purem Herzen, aber in Wirklichkeit,
machen die das doch, natürlich wollen die alle diese Gewinne einstreichen.
Natürlich springen auch die meisten Leute sicherlich auf, wenn der Zug schon eigentlich schon längst weit weit losgefahren ist, ne? Ich meine, bei Bitcoin, klar, wenn ich's in den Nachrichten lese und der Kurs sich schon verfünffacht hat, dann ruft natürlich jetzt ein Privat an, sagt, wie kann ich jetzt auch noch damit machen, die sind natürlich dann die letzten sozusagen.
Unter Umständen haben die anderen schon längst vorher verkauft, die schon früh genug dabei waren und die Gewinne eingestrichen haben. Das gleich.
Ja, aber ich kann dir sagen, als jemand, der früh Bitcoin verkauft hat, bist du jetzt auch nicht das kommst du dir auch nicht wie der klügste vor, ne? Also da äh gibt es durchaus ähm.
Ich weiß noch nicht in den Anfängen, dass Tim mal mit Holgi drüber gesprochen hatte und ihr, glaube ich, auch mal ein paar besessen habt. Also, wenn ihr sie gehalten hättet, dann klar, dann würde Tim jetzt tatsächlich Millionär sein bei den fünf Millionen in der Liste.
So viel waren's leider nie.
Du kannst ja also Tims Bitcoin, Wallet müsstest du eigentlich einsehen können.
Na ja, kannst du ja, also kannst keine brauche ich jetzt auch nicht geheim zu halten, bei mir auf der Webseite steht ja auch eines meiner Bitcoin-Worlles und da kann man ja äh auf Blockchain äh Info auch genau sehen, wie da der Stand ist. Also das ist im Moment natürlich viele äh
viele hundert Prozent im im Plus, aber äh reicht jetzt noch nicht für einen Ruhestand, eher für vielleicht einen Monat oder zwei.
Bei Tim könnte das länger sein. Da guckt er nur.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich dazu sagen soll. Ich meine, ich hatte, ich hatte ein paar Bitcoin, ich habe natürlich auch ein paar davon irgendwann mal äh in Panik verkauft und äh konnte von diesen richtigen Situationen niemals so richtig
äh profitieren. Äh am Ende war's unterm Strich für mich eher ein positives Geschäft, aber ich bin äh sehr schlecht in diesen Dingen. Daran hat sich wenig äh geändert.
Na ja, Moment, Tim, da gucken wir aber mal. So, hier ist ja ein Bitcoin, wo ist denn mal hier ein Bitcoin? Wallet von Tim. Aha, hier haben wir auch schon.
Wallet ID. Dann schauen wir mal, was der Tim gerade wert ist. In Bitcoin.
Wert bin, lässt sich ja überhaupt nicht in Geld oder in Bitcoin ausdrücken.
Jetzt jetzt kommt wieder der Waldorfschüler durch.
Das auf äh Meterebene eher angegebene Bitcoin Konto hat gerade eine feine Balance von elftausend Dollar.
Oh
Uns mal sehen. Ein richtig, richtig großem Geschäft bin ich. Ja, wollen wir uns noch länger über meine äh persönlichen Finanzen unterhalten oder sind wir jetzt durch mit der Sendung?
Die Frage ist einfach nur, wann brauchst du deinen Wohnwagen zurück, Tim?
Können wir da vielleicht noch, könnte ich den vielleicht noch ein bisschen länger geliehen haben?
Eingestellt hier im Wallstreet Forum.
Ja, aber der geht jetzt viral hier.
Tim, ich vermiete dir den dann auch zurück.
Wirklich. Oh, das ist aber nett von dir. Äh du bist echt so ein Kapitalist. Im im Black Hoodie.
Äh Stern aufer Mütze, aber im tiefen Herzen einfach Kapital, Magnat.
Was wir jetzt noch nicht so behandelt haben, ist, dass das natürlich auch nochmal alles mit so einer, mit dieser Internetkultur einhergeht, ne, wie das so ist mit solchen Foren. Äh die bezeichnen sich dann als ähm
Mit Bloomberg Terminal und äh oder sich selber als degenerierte posten regelmäßig äh Lostporn und äh,
äh Gainporn oder Winpoint, wo sie quasi ihr, also Portfolio, Screenshots äh posten.
Und ja, illustrieren halt diese irre.
Losgelöstheit des Aktien- und Finanzwesens von der Realität da draußen. Und das ist natürlich schon echt auf eine Weise absurd,
wir uns eigentlich gerade in in einer absolut globalen Krise befinden. Der DAX war, glaube ich, im weil wann hatte der sein Allzeithoch im November oder im Dezember?
Tausend Punkten.
Äh irgendwelche redet Leute äh machen äh Short Squeeses, der Bitcoin stand bei vierzigtausend US-Dollar und das ist ja alles irgendwie sehr ähm.
Also es es ist schon wirklich ziemlich absurd.
Aber okay, das ist jetzt auch keine neue Erkenntnis. Möchtest du noch irgendwelche abschließenden äh äh Worte sagen, Daniel zu dem Thema?
Soll ich noch ein Gebet sprechen oder wie? Nein, ich denke, wir haben aus allen Perspektiven irgendwie alles behandelt und ja, ich bin gespannt, äh in welche Richtung das läuft und wir werden ja sicherlich nochmal vielleicht in einer der nächsten Sendungen nochmal darüber sprechen vielleicht.
Vielleicht noch ein kleiner dystopischer Gedanke äh zum Schluss, um so die Laune nochmal runterzubringen. Ich meine, wir haben ja gesehen, wie sich so
die rechten Horden und Traumpisten und so weiter äh im Netz verabredet haben, umso allerlei,
böse Maßnahmen einzuleiten, so als wenn sich sowas sozusagen dann auch auf die
Aktienkurse von Unternehmen richten kann, dann könnte man ja auch durchaus vorstellen, dass das sozusagen auch so politischer Aktivismus in die falsche Richtung gehen.
Könnte, ne, dass hier irgendwie zukunftsweisende Unternehmen oder äh Unternehmen, die jetzt besonders humanistische Prinzipien äh hochhalten
entsprechend unter Druck kommen. Siehst du diese Gefahr oder ist das jetzt von mir so ein bisschen weit hergeholt?
Du meinst, das ist politisch ausgenutzt wird, solche Formen?
Ich meine, wir müssen ja gar nicht so weit gehen. Ich meine, diese Tweets, die Trump alle abgelassen hat, ähm die haben ja schon genau in die ein oder andere Richtung geführt. Die haben ja auch viele Unternehmen geschadet oder geholfen. Ähm da fängt's ja schon mal an.
Bin mal gespannt auf irgendwelche Untersuchungen, die in der Zukunft stattfinden, ob da nicht sicherlich hoffentlich nicht er, aber sicherlich einige Familienmitglieder nicht, die ich auch da die Taschen voll gemacht haben. Also, würde im Teufel zugehen, wenn das nicht passiert ist. Ähm aber,
Durchaus, also das als Instrument, sich vorzustellen, ähm halte ich für durchaus möglich.
Okay. Nicht, dass die Leute jetzt zu mit zu guter Laune äh aus dieser Sendung rausgehen
Ja, muss man aber auf jeden Fall mal im Blick halten. Ist ein extrem komplexes System, bei dem ich mich zugegebenermaßen bisher noch nie so richtig äh orientiert habe
oder orientiert bekommen habe. Und ich glaube, so geht's äh vielen Leuten auch, aber es äh durchaus sinnvoll da mal vielleicht ein bisschen mehr Hirnschmalz noch reinzustecken, um diese Mechanismen auch zu verstehen, all die auch natürlich zum gesamtgesellschaftlichen
beitragen auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise.
Also, drei Nachrichten machen wir noch. Clear View AI, äh Clear-View AI hatten wir äh behandelt, ist eine US-Firma, die Fotos von Webseiten scrapt.
Und daraus biometrische Profile macht, also die äh Facebook, die scrapen irgendwelche anderen Plattformen, wo es Bilder gibt, wo gekennzeichnet ist, wer eine Person ist.
Und das haben sie ähm den US Behörden zur Verfügung stellt, den Strafverfolgungsbehörden, um dort eine Gesichtssuche zu machen. Ne, also du hast die Situation es gibt jetzt hier irgendwie einen Menschen, du willst vielleicht wissen, wer das ist,
weil der bei diesem Capitolsturm,
dabei gesichtet wurde, wie er irgendwo sich ungebührlich verhält. Und jetzt, dann würdest du dieses Gesicht eben bei rein,
und die haben halt einen ganz normalen biometrische Erkennungs äh Software auf sehr, sehr viele Bilder laufen lassen und können dir dann eben potenziell sagen, hierbei handelt es sich um folgende Person.
Ähm.
Creepy so oder so. Wir hatten drüber gesprochen. Das Problem ist, dass sie also ja hier eine Datenbank über Personen bilden.
Dazu keine Zustimmung erteilt haben und das ist natürlich nach DSGVO,
Einfach so nicht zulässig, was sie da tun. Also es darf nicht jemand äh deine Bilder scrapen und äh biometrisches Profil von dir anlegen, was nämlich damit personenbezogene Daten über dich sind, ohne dass du dort deine ähm Zustimmung zugegeben hast.
Ähm jetzt hat vor einiger Zeit der äh Cantorke.
Ein CC Mitglied, was sich da schon seit langer Zeit politisch engagiert, auch im Freifunkumfeld aktiv ist im IT Security-Bereich aktiv ist.
Einfach mal ganz klassisch zusammen mit Business, der österreichischen äh Daten.
Schutz, NGO Max Sims von Max Sims gegründet, der ja auch schon äh zweimal bei uns äh zum Podcast äh zu Gast war. Die haben also hier eine ähm,
Beschwerde gegen Clear View AI eingebracht und zwar beim Hamburger,
Datenschutzbeauftragten, der hat das dann elf Monate untersucht und herausgestellt, festgestellt, ja, das geht so nicht.
Und jetzt wurde eine quasi eine Anordnung äh.
Erlassen. Das Clearview AI diesen diese biometrischen Hashtag, dieses biometrische Profil von.
Matthias Marx wird ja im Artikel genannt, äh das muss wohl sein Pseudonym sein. Ähm gelöscht löschen muss, ja? Allerdings.
Haben sie nicht angeordnet, dass sie die Bilder löschen müssen, also sie müssen nur diesen biometrischen Fingerabdruck, den sie daraus errechnet haben, löschen und nicht die Bilder, müssen das bis zum zwölften Februar machen, können auch noch drauf antworten. Ähm.
Und vor allem wurde aber keine generelle Lösung angeordnet, wie das jetzt eigentlich von,
an dieser Stelle verlangt wurde. Und ich finde das ein bisschen überraschend, weil ja eigentlich vor allem der äh Hamburger Datenschutzbeauftragte ähm.
Äh Johannes Kasper nicht dafür bekannt ist, äh jetzt irgendwie nur so halbe Sachen zu machen. Ja, das äh ist also so ein bisschen,
ähm schade, dass hier nicht äh keine europäische Order erlassen wurde, dass äh alle diese Bilder gelöscht werden müssen. Das heißt, jede Einzelperson.
Muss jetzt von einmal eine Datenschutzanfrage stellen. Im Prinzip sagen, ich will eine Kopie meiner Daten haben.
Und dann äh kann man dann ähm den Einspruch erheben und hat eben den Löschungs.
Anspruch, ja? Aber das muss jetzt eben einzeln muss jede Person einzeln machen.
Ähm ich will jetzt nicht sagen, lasst uns ein Sub Radit gründen, ähm um das äh organisiert zu machen.
Wir haben ja schon hier unser und in den Shownots gibt's den Link, wo man eben äh zu die äh findet, ja, für Staaten unterschiedlicher ähm.
Unterschiedlicher kann man also ein die Indexing-Request stellen an.
Und ja, kann man also sagen, sehr schön, dass dieser diese Präzedenz geschaffen wurde durch äh kann Torke in Zusammenarbeit mit,
Schön, dass hier auch gezeigt wurde, wie man's macht. Und darf nicht vergessen, das erinnert natürlich alles an
äh insbesondere ja, sage ich mal, den Gründungsmythos will ich fast sagen, von Neub, äh denn Max Srems ist ja damals im Prinzip damit berühmt geworden, ziemlich genau das mit Facebook gemacht zu haben. Also DSGVO-Anfragen stellen, ähm feststellen, dass die nicht den,
Anforderungen erfüllen, beziehungsweise damals gab's ja noch nicht mal die DSGVO und so weiter und so fort. Insofern tut es dem Beispiel gleich und sorgt dafür, dass ihr aus dieser biometrischen Datenbank,
gelöscht werden.
Müsst und ähm da kann man zumindest Parallelen, glaube ich, dazu sehen, äh dass man die Schweinebluten sehen will, wie es auch bei Wall Street Bats der Fall ist, ja? Oder.
Aber die Frage ist, was ist was ist da für mich drin? Also was ist da für eine Marge äh.
Ein paar Bilder von dir, ist doch schick und deinen biometrischen Fingerabdruck. Das ist doch fein für dich.
Ich mache jetzt aber ich mache jetzt Aktivismus, aber nur noch, wenn da auch was bei für mich bei rumkommt.
Okay, pass auf, dann gebe ich dir einen Tipp. Ähm deshalb jetzt unter uns, Tim, ne? Clear View AI Shorten. Todsicheres Ding.
Dann kommt der rennet und und und kauft die alle.
So, wen man auch shorten kann, zumindest kurzfristig,
ist Evoted das ist ein also wir haben,
über hier schon einmal ausführlich gesprochen. Ich glaube, in der LNP drei, zwei, eins mit dem schönen Titel Verluste durch außergewöhnliche Schadensfälle.
Und bei E-Moted handelt es sich um eine relativ berüchtigte Gang aus Erpressern. Und die ist relativ.
Erfolgreich seit zwanzig vierzehn ungefähr aktiv, funktioniert also folgendermaßen, wir haben ich hab das damals wie gesagt in der LNP, drei, zwei, eins, das ist sehr viel ausführlicher erklärt, aber vielleicht nochmal ganz kurz,
zur Strategie von und wie sich das entwickelt hat. Das Geschäftsmodell ist folgendermaßen, du nimmst die Dateien einer Person,
verschlüsselt sie alle, die Person möchte die Dateien natürlich zurückhaben und du verlangst für den Key zur Entschlüsselung der Daten ein Lösegeld,
Dieses Lösegeld lässt du dir in Bitcoin auszahlen ähm und jetzt hat sich dieses Geschäftsmodell von anfänglich zu einer Flatrate, wo man einfach pro Fall sowas wie fünfhundert oder tausend US-Dollar verlangt hat.
Ähm durch verschiedene.
Verschiedenen Evolutionsdruck weiterentwickelt. Das eine ist, wenn du Flatrate von allen das Gleiche verlangst, dass du natürlich potentiell von einigen zu viel verlangst,
und von anderen viel zu wenig. Ja, es macht halt einen Unterschied, ob du ein Unternehmen in deinen Fängen hast oder eine Privatperson. Ähm das andere ist, dein natürlicher Feind ist das Backup.
Und das Backup mitzulöschen ist potenziell nicht ganz so einfach, zumindest nicht im massenhaften Prinzip
Also du hast letztendlich als Angreifer, der sich darauf spezialisieren möchte zu machen, zwei allgemeine Herangehensweisen, ne? Das eine ist der
das massenhafte Vorgehen, wo du einfach sagst, okay, wir machen das hier dunkel durch, ne
Flatrate für alle, das Geschäftsmodell skaliert, wir haben damit wenig Arbeit und optimieren halt nicht die Preise. Die andere ist, du machst es zielgerichtet und investierst quasi in deine Angriffsopfer mehr, ähm um zu um sicherzustellen, dass du
lukrativer Angriffsopfer hast, was gemacht hat, ist im Prinzip so ein Hybridmodell. Die haben massenhaft infiziert,
und haben dann aber quasi nur bei äh bei lukrativen Zielen.
Sich darum bemüht ein Lösegeld zu erpressen. Also
quasi gesagt, so nur da, wo viel zu holen ist, investieren wir unsere Arbeit, um dieses äh um dieses Erpressungs
auch durchzuziehen
Insbesondere ist das deshalb spannend, weil der natürliche Fight eben das Backup ist. Und da kommst du dann eben in so eine individuelle Betreuung. Das heißt, du musst äh du willst nicht ein, nicht nur einen Computer infizieren, sondern möglichst ein ganzes Unternehmen. Dieses Unternehmen hat Backup-Systeme und die musst du dir auch noch unter den Nagel reißen
Wie gesagt, in LMP drei, zwei, eins ausführlicher erklärt, aber das das allgemeine Ziel ist, du infizierst einen Rechner in der Regel über irgendwelche E-Mail-Anhänger.
Und von diesem Rechner aus musst du dir jetzt deine Privilegien ausweiten. Das hat dir an diesem Rechner jetzt im Zweifelsfall eine Person, die nur Nutzerinnenrechte hat und du musst jetzt dafür sorgen,
dass du Domänen, Administrator wirst. Was ist eine Domäne? Ähm im Prinzip in großen Unternehmen werden.
Die Rechner quasi,
Zentral verwaltet, also das Unternehmen hat von mir aus eintausend Arbeitsplätze oder eintausend Mitarbeiterinnen, fünfhundert Arbeitsplätze und jetzt sind diese Rechner alle in eine Domäne eingebunden und durch diese Domäne kannst du ähm
Gruppenrichtlinien äh setzen, die für alle diese Rechner gelten. Also der das diese Domäne, das Active Directory kann,
Regeln für diese Rechner definieren, die mächtiger sind als das, was,
lokal administrieren kannst. Ein Beispiel. Du sagst, okay, auf all unseren Rechnern soll folgender Virenscanner installiert sein. Dann kannst du das über eine Gruppenrichtlinie.
Dass der installiert ist. Oder du kannst sagen, auf keinem unserer Rechner soll eine Nutzerin drucken können, dann kannst du irgendwie eine Gruppenrichtlinie machen und die möglichst.
Verhindert. Also ein Flottenmanagementsystem. Sehr schön, weil man dadurch einheitliche,
ähm Verhältnisse schaffen kann und eben diese Flotte managebar wird und du auch eine Gleichförmigkeit deiner äh deines IT-Sicherheitsmanagements hinkriegen kannst, aber eben auch sehr gut,
wenn wenn es Angreifern gelingt, dieses Domänenkontrollsystem zu übernehmen.
Weil sie dann zum Beispiel auf allen Rechnern gleichzeitig zum Beispiel sagen können, okay Freunde, jetzt bitte mal alle Dateien verschlüsseln.
Was, wenn du ein größeres Unternehmen bist und eine größere Flotte hast, kommst du eigentlich nicht darum herum, so ein Active Directory zu nutzen.
Was leider viele machen ist, dass sie ihre Backup-Server auch in dieses Active Directory einbinden. Und das ist natürlich relativ schlecht,
weil die Angreifer ohnehin das Ziel haben, das Active Directory zu übernehmen, das machst du üblicherweise so, indem du auf dem lokalen Rechner für Störfelle sorgst.
Und äh darauf wartest, dass ein Administrator sich darauf anmeldet.
Und dann hast du das Passwort und dann kontrollierst du eben nicht mehr nur einen Rechner, sondern alle.
Ähm und wenn das der Fall ist und die Administratoren äh so klug waren, ihr Backup-System auch in die Domäne einzubinden.
Dann sagst du eben, alles klar, die Backup-Server jetzt bitte einmal wieder mehr Platz äh auf der Festplatte machen.
Dann hast du also die Backups zerstört und dann schreitest du zur Tat und machst die Verschlüsselung auf den Fightservern auf den Endgeräten und dann hast du dem deinen Zielpersonen eben nicht nur ihre,
aktuellen Daten genommen, sondern eben auch die Wiederherstellungsmöglichkeiten und das stärkt deine Verhandlungsposition ungemein, wenn du von denen dann äh Bitcoin verlangst.
Waren sehr gut darin äh und vor allem sehr elegant, weil sie ähm erstmal auf die erfolgreiche Infektion längere Zeit äh sich.
Nichts haben folgen lassen. Also sie haben einmal infiziert,
Und dann erstmal, dann verging in der Regel so ein paar Wochen zwischen zwei und vier Wochen, bis die sich weiter engagiert haben und dann wirklich zur Tat geschritten sind. Ähm,
Das führt dann zu so Sachen bei jemandem wie mir, dessen Job es ist, solche Fälle aufzuräumen, äh zu so Sachen,
sich Leute bei dir melden und sagen, ja hier war irgendwas mit dem Virenscan, aber ich glaube, wir haben die Sache jetzt im Griff.
Und äh zwei oder vier Wochen später dann äh sehr aufgeregt bei dir anrufen.
Und äh dich um Hilfe bitten mit dieser äh Situation umzugehen. Also auf jeden Fall so ein bisschen die.
Gefürchtetsten und besten in dem Bereich oder erfolgreichsten in diesem Bereich. Berüchtigsten in diesem Bereich. Gibt's auch andere Gruppen? Aber imotec, sagen wir mal, war für viele Unternehmen in den letzten Jahren,
dass der das Albtraumszenario,
und äh ja, für Leute, die in der IT-Sicherheit arbeiten, ja gewissermaßen auch, also du weißt, wenn du irgendwo so einen Fall hast, hast, kannst du auf jeden Fall mal alle anderen Termine absagen.
Und ähm muss sehr sauber vorgehen, um eben eine neue IT-Infrastruktur aufzubauen, wo du die Leute nicht mehr drin hast.
Wie schütze ich mich denn grundsätzlich davor? Also ich meine, es gibt ja diese Cyberax und dieser Welt, die so Privileg Excess Management machen, damit ich halt eben nicht zu jedem Zeitpunkt der Admin sein kann, ist das der richtige Weg oder was gibt's da für Methoden als Unternehmen?
Also die besten, die besten Wege sich gegen zu schützen sind ähm also als allererstes,
die Makros äh per Gruppenrichtlinie deaktivieren oder zumindest dafür sorgen, dass du nur von deinem Unternehmen signierte Makros ausführst.
Ähm damit kannst du quasi präventiv ähm dagegen.
Vorgehen, um eben die in diese Infektionswahrscheinlichkeiten ähm einzuschränken.
Weiterer Fall wäre solche Fernzugänge wie äh Teamviewer oder auch Remote Desktop Sachen drauf zu verzichten oder zumindest mit einem Zweifaktor Authentifizierungssystem zu nutzen, damit die nicht auf diesem Wege reinkommen.
Ähm.
Also die üblichen Angriffswege irgendwie eindämmen, ja, da gibt's natürlich dann auch noch diese ganzen Scherze wie äh Virenscan auf den E-Mail-Server und was nicht alles, was du da eben an präventiven Maßnahmen so sich dir anbieten, die aber eben alle auch,
äh nur eingeschränkt äh eingeschränkten Schutz,
Mit anderen Worten, du darfst nicht nur präventiv vorgehen, sondern willst natürlich auch eine Detektionsmöglichkeiten haben
Also wenn so eine Infektion stattgefunden hat, gucken,
ne, dass du erkennst, wenn einer deiner Rechner sich auf einmal komisch verhält, irgendwelche Verbindungen macht, auch das ist natürlich,
mit äh hundertprozentiger Wahrscheinlichkeit möglich. Deswegen besteht der finale und der der wichtigste Schutz in dem Bereich natürlich in den Wiederherstellungsmöglichkeiten,
also dafür zu sorgen, dass du ein Backup hast, was nicht in die Domäne eingebunden ist.
Also du willst im Prinzip deinen Backup-Server soll etwas sein, was nur Backups entgegennimmt.
Den über unter keinen Umständen überhaupt erlaubt, das Backups manipuliert werden, ne? Also die Systeme, die Gebäckup werden dürfen nicht das Recht haben, ihre eigenen Backups wieder zu löschen.
Ähm und du willst, dass dieses Backupsystem am besten ja halt vollständig autark steht.
Und äh also wir raten dann den Kunden gerne dazu, ne, also der Backup-Server steht da. Der einzige Möglichkeit, die einzige Möglichkeit, diesen Backup-Server zu administrieren, ist die Tastatur und der Bildschirm,
die man da dran stöpseln muss. Und der Service, welcher Backup-Service auch immer das ist,
darf eben nur die Funktionalität haben, Backups abzuliefern, aber nur Administratorinnen, die live an dem Gerät stehen, dürfen die Möglichkeit haben, Backups zu löschen.
Das hilft dir schon mal sehr viel, weil du dann die Angriffsfläche auf diesem Backup-Server halt maximal ähm reduziert hast. Viele Unternehmen haben dann natürlich auch nochmal regelmäßige Backups von Backup-Server, die Offsite gespeichert werden. Ne, also irgendwie,
was da jeden Freitag rausgezogen wird und ins Regal gestellt wird. Derartige Dinge.
Allerdings entpuppt sich auch in der Realität, also wenn du Backups hast.
Hast du meistens immer noch das Problem, die wieder einzuspielen? Ähm und zwar.
Es hilft dir nichts, wenn du jetzt nur die Systeme gesichert hast, weil die Systeme sind ja potenziell infiziert. Ja, das heißt, wenn du jetzt eine Umgebung hast, die an diesem Active Directory hängt und du weißt,
Leute konnten über Active Directory Gruppenrichtlinien im Prinzip alles mit deiner Flotte machen, dann kann das eben auch sein, dass sie weitere Reinfektionsvektoren auf den Systemen angebracht haben, beziehungsweise, dass jeder Computer, der an der Domäne hängt,
eben potenziell gegen dich arbeitet, also deine Passwörter mitschneidet oder sonst was. Ähm.
Das heißt, du brauchst eigentlich auch so einen Wieder äh Anlaufkonzept. Ähm in dem du potenziell.
Systeme, Konfigurationen und Nutzdaten getrennt wiederherstellen kannst, ne? Also nicht nur zu sagen, okay, wir stellen das jetzt aus dem Backup wieder her, weil wenn du das System aus dem Backup wiederherstellst,
kannst du nicht der Integrität des äh Systems vertrauen. Also willst du eigentlich,
nicht nur Backups haben, sondern auch ein Wiederanlaufkonzept. Du hast ja jetzt hier potenziell wirklich viele Rechner, viele Systeme, die miteinander interagieren, voneinander abhängig sind. Und du willst ja nicht nur die Systeme wiederherstellen, sondern im betriebsbereiten Zustand.
Und das kannst du natürlich am besten ähm am besten, wenn du es in irgendeiner Weise geplant hast. Ja, das ist also meistens ist das so,
dass du in solchen Fällen halt da stehst vor den Trümmern, dass Unternehmen in irgendeiner Form von Notbetrieb ist, wenn es das geschafft hat.
Du dann mit denen gemeinsam erarbeiten musst, okay, wie stellen wir das denn hier wieder her? Welche Systeme brauchen wir für einen Betrieb, auf welche können wir vielleicht,
zunächst noch verzichten, ne, wovon sind wir abhängig? Und da kommt relativ viel sehr schnell zusammen, was so ein typisches,
Unternehmen irgendwie hat, ne? Die haben ja nicht nur einen Computer und E-Mail, sondern die müssen an diese Plattform angebunden sein und das System und so weiter. Und dann kommen so Sachen damit hinzu, dass du teilweise Systeme hast, wenn du da den Stand von gestern wieder herstellst,
Dann sind die äh gewissermaßen unbrauchbar diese Systeme. Ähm weil du eben eine eine Echtzeit-Abhängigkeiten,
hast im im Betrieb dieser Systeme.
Also äh um die Frage zusammenfassend zu beantworten. Das Wichtigste ist Backup und Wiederherstellungskonzept, weil das das ist, was den Unterschied macht zwischen Ruin,
und potenziell einfach nur einer Krise,
dann natürlich detektive Maßnahmen und präventive Maßnahmen, aber aus, weil du eben nicht ausschließen kannst, dass dir das passiert,
denke ich, Backup und Wiederanlaufkonzept hier die wichtigsten Sachen und beim Backup eben dafür sorgen, dass das auf eine Weise angefertigt wird, dass egal wie deine IT-Infrastruktur kompromittiert wird, diese Backups nicht mit draufgehen. Und das ist eben bei einem,
bei einem in deine Domäne eingebundenen Backup nicht unbedingt der Fall.
Das also ist diese Gruppe äh also jetzt hier seit sieben Jahren äh erfolgreich. Da gab es jetzt die von internationalen Polizeibehörden. Die Meldung, sie hätten also jetzt diese,
Bande ähm,
erwischt ihre IT-Infrastruktur übernommen und ausgeschaltet und die äh Täter verhaftet. Ähm.
Leider gibt's da aber nicht so viel weitere ähm Informationen zu, also außer, dass äh alle stolz berichtet haben, jo hier, wir haben's geschafft und so und im da stellt man sich natürlich jetzt schon so ein bisschen die Frage,
Was ist mit den aktuellen Opfern, die vielleicht jetzt grade in Verhandlungen waren über den Kauf eines äh Wiederherstellungsschlüssels, ne? Können die jetzt noch ihre Deals abschließen oder nicht? Ähm.
Und die andere Sache ist die Gefahr ist natürlich nicht für die Leute gebannt, weil das, was die machen, ist relativ einfach und.
So
Also, es ist nicht so, als wäre jetzt das Risiko weg für deine IT, nur weil diese eine Bande das nicht mehr macht. Es gibt genug andere, die das natürlich in ähnlicher Form machen.
Die benutzten auch mitunterhalt Tools wie Trickpot oder so, die kann sich jeder runterladen. Das haben sie modular verwendet, ne? Das war jetzt nicht irgendwie nur eine eigene Schadsoftware, die sie da verwendet haben, sondern wir benutzen halt viele Sachen, die man.
Auch nachmachen kann. Und ähm also ich gehe nicht davon aus, dass das jetzt wirklich eine.
Mittelfristige oder langfristige Entwarnung hinsichtlich dieses Risikoszenarios betrifft, aber immerhin ist es ein Erfolg für die Polizeibehörden,
diese auch diese Kriminellen in irgendeiner Weise verfolgt zu haben und potenziell,
jetzt einer einer Strafverfolgung zuführen zu können. Ganz unterhaltsam, es gibt da so ein Video, das über einen,
rate in der Ukraine, wo sie dann echt, das ist dann ungefähr so, wie man's sich vorstellt, stehen irgendwie überall so Festplatten und irgendwelche echt so äh crazy Computer rum,
dann werden die Schränke aufgemacht und da irgendwelche Platinbarren rausgeholt, ne? Ähm das ist äh sehr ähm sehr unterhaltsames ähm,
Video von dem von dem Raid, was man sich da anschauen kann. Gibt's natürlich jetzt auch wieder die Frage, findet man das gut oder schlecht, dass solche Videos veröffentlicht werden und so weiter,
Ähm ich blicke da jetzt natürlich mit einem,
Ja, also weil ich mit diesen Leuten eben unbekannterweise schon öfter zu tun hatte, äh da natürlich auch durchaus drauf und denke mir so, ach, okay, die sind das, die sind das also, die dir diese schlaflose Nächte eingebracht haben.
Ähm und äh ja, ich denke aber, dass sich das das Geschäftsmodell ist zu lukrativ und zu,
erfolgreich, als dass man jetzt für Unternehmen sagen könnte, so hu, die Jungs sind hinter Gittern, das passiert mir jetzt nicht mehr, ne, also die für die Lage der IT-Sicherheit und der Angriffe, die die da durchführen und die katastrophale,
Situation, die eben in den Unternehmen herrscht und die hat hier sehr viel Verwundbarkeit und Angriffsfläche in Richtung solcher Angriffe zeigen, hat sich eigentlich nichts geändert.
Aber man muss auch mal wieder sagen, ne, wir haben ja hier Zeiten, wo der BND jetzt demnächst äh Mobilfunkanbieter hacken soll und das IT-Sicherheitsgesetz, irgendwelche äh Gütesiegel für Kühlschränke verspricht,
muss man jetzt einfach mal sagen, hier internationale Polizei, Polizeizusammenarbeit hat jetzt offenbar auch.
Diese Leute ähm dingfest zu machen. Was man jetzt auch mal gucken muss, ist, sind da wirklich diese Leute ähm verhaftet worden oder potenziell,
nur ein paar Bauernopfer, sodass die Angriffsaktivität vielleicht in paar Wochen wieder losgeht. Das werden wir dann noch sehen.
Alles klar. Das ist also zu, wie gesagt, ich habe da durchaus meine Faszination mit und da ist relativ viel drüber gesprochen in der NLP drei, zwei, eins Verluste durch außergewöhnliche Schadensfälle.
Tja und dann hätte ich jetzt noch so das letzte Thema. Ähm.
Impfportale. Hat mal einer von euch versucht, äh da einen Termin zu registrieren für jemanden und äh gibt's da gibt's da.
Los Poren, den ihr mir im Portal Lossporn, von dem wir hier berichten können.
Also ich nicht. Du Daniel?
Ja, für die für die Großmutter meiner Freundin, was tatsächlich sehr mehrere Tage gedauert hat, also online ging überhaupt nichts,
Telefon-Hotline war besetzt, bis wir auf eine App ausgewichen sind, die ähm wenn denn das Besetztzeichen vorbei ist, dann wieder anruft und das ging dann relativ zügig.
Äh kannst du die mal empfehlen? Wie heißt die?
Zwei, ich glaube, vom iPhone ging das gar nicht. Es waren, glaube ich, in Android-App, habe sie aber gerade nicht zur Hand, aber kann ich nochmal den nachtragen? Äh Hessen.
Welches Bundesland? Hm. Ja, also einige Bundesländer scheinen auf jeden Fall äh ordentlich Probleme zu haben mit diesen ganzen Anmeldungssystemen.
Bundesland keine.
Na ja, ich weiß nicht, in Berlin.
Dann ziehe ich dahin, also.
Es gibt gibt halt welche, die einfach direkt nur online Anmeldungen haben und die dann entsprechend äh bestürmt wurden und dann gibt's halt äh Länder, glaube ich, in Berlin läuft es so, wo halt erstmal ein Brief kommen muss, bevor du überhaupt einen Termin
vereinbaren kannst. Derzeit zumindest.
Also ich hatte ähm für einen Freund Bekanntschaften mit dem äh Impfportal in NRW.
Und äh das also ein äh Mensch, vierundachtzig Jahre alt, Lungenkrank, Bergbau geprägt, ja, die.
Bergmanns Lunge, Berufskrankheit so und so. Ähm,
sagen wir mal wirklich so, jemand den jetzt in die schon erste Reihe stellen würdest oder zweite Reihe spätestens bei diesen Impfangelegenheiten? Und es ging damit los, dass äh man sich dort mit einer E-Mail-Adresse registrieren muss,
jetzt hatten wir bei diesem Menschen das Glück, dass er über eine E-Mail-Adresse verfügt und sehr fit ist im Umgang mit Computern.
Und dann kam diese E-Mail, wo dran stand, okay, hier bitte einmal auf den Link klicken, um zu bestätigen, dass das deine E-Mail-Adresse ist, ne. Also, da wird ja dann einfach das System ist ja, man man bekommt quasi eine Zufallscode zugesendet und wenn man dann diesen Link aufruft,
wird dadurch bestätigt, dass man diese E-Mail gelesen hat, ja? Was sagt diese Plattform? Ja, der Token ist ungültig.
Hatten also waren offenbar so überlastet, dass sie sich den ihren eigenen Token nicht merken konnten.
Oh Mann.
Da wurde dann ich zur Hilfe gerufen, was ich gemacht habe war, okay, ich habe dann einfach nochmal neu angemeldet, habe wieder dann war der Token gültig. Dann war ich also in der Situation, dass ich da äh mich unter dem Namen meines Freundes anmelden konnte. Ähm.
Und dann wurden mir Termine gezeigt, da war der nächste, den ich dann auswählen konnte, am vierzehnten März,
Als nächstes wurden mir dann Urzeiten in so einer Staffelung angezeigt von vier Minuten, konntest du dann deinen Impftermin wählen und an dem Punkt war dann immer, wenn du darauf klickst, kam dann zurück, es tut mir leid, es gibt gar keine Termine.
Also die Plattform in einem absolut instabilen Zustand,
ähm und kein erfolgreiches Abschließen eines Impftermin ist möglich. Wir haben dann ja auch einfach immer wieder diese eins eins, sechs, eins, eins, sieben angewählt,
um dort da, das ist die zentrale Ordnung, wenn du dann da über äh.
Landest du bei der deines Bundeslandes, gibt natürlich auch direkt die Gezielte von deinem Bundesland und dann, wenn du dich da, wenn du da bist, dann guckt halt das Gesetz zeichnen, kannst es wieder versuchen.
Und es ist so,
absehbar, dass das äh dass es da einen äh massiven Ansturm geben würde und in Nordrhein-Westfalen war's dann eben oft tatsächlich so, dass sie gesagt haben, ja am Montag ab so und so viel Uhr können sich dann alle registrieren. Und das ist natürlich genau so verlaufen, wie es zu erwarten war und man fragt sich wirklich,
also das ist so ein vorhersehbares Problem, dass man sich wirklich fragt, was für Laschets da irgendwie die Dinger programmiert haben, dass dass du äh dass du das nicht hinkriegst, ja, dass es auch wirklich.
Also es ist wirklich zum Heulen und ja, eine,
mit mit in meinem Alter gucke ich mir das natürlich an und denke mir ja, okay, bis ich irgendwann dran bin, werden alle diese Probleme gelöst sein. Aber du sitzt da neben jemandem, der äh ja, weiß ich nicht, außer Atem ist, weil er ein paar Meter gegangen ist.
Ähm und siehst, das ist halt jetzt nicht lustig ist,
was da an an Verpackungen äh abgeliefert wurde und ähm ja aber jetzt muss man natürlich sagen, ne, wenn du ein Plattform baust und die ist in der Lage so und so viele Nutzerinnen abzufackeln,
äh abzufeiern, dann ist das halt sobald dafür, sobald du prozentual darüber bist, ist es ja nicht
dann wird die Plattform ja instabil und ist am Ende in der Lage niemanden mehr abzufeiern da. Und das ist genau das, was hier mit diesem überlasteten System dann passiert ist
und das ist wirklich zum Heulen, ja? Es ist wirklich katastrophal, da mit Leuten zu sitzen, die neben dir stehen und irgendwie atmen.
Und du siehst ja OK wird jetzt nichts in den nächsten Monaten, weil im Moment rufst du dieses NRW Portal auf und da steht gibt keine Termine. Arschlecken tut mir Leid.
Und es ist so, es gibt so einfache, ja, das hat ja nicht, nicht nur was damit zu tun, dass du eine kompetente Person brauchst, die dir diese Plattform programmiert, sondern du kannst ja auch zum Beispiel sagen, okay, am Montag alle mit,
und dann nimmst du halt irgendein Zufallsmerk, weil nachdem du die Leute selektierst und sagst, alle, die am ersten eines Monats geboren sind oder, oder, oder, ja.
Masse Lottozahlen nachher, sagst, so, jetzt sind alle, die am äh siebenundzwanzigsten eines Monats äh geboren sind, oder, oder, oder, gibt's ja tausend Möglichkeiten, ja, dafür da den Ansturm niedrig zu halten.
Aber naja, da wir die Impfstoffbesorgung ja auch verkacken, ist das vielleicht gar nicht so dramatisch.
Es ist auch durchaus möglich, ein System so zu bauen, dass es auch mit einem großen Ansturm erstmal klarkommt. So, also es ist es muss ja nicht gleich schon am allerersten Schritt vollständig in die Hose gehen. Ähm ja und
wenn du auch erstmal nur mit einer Webseite äh kommst, die statisch ausgeliefert wird, die einfach beliebige Zugriffe verkraftet und dann entsprechendem,
Wartelisten ausgibt oder was weiß ich.
Wir haben ja im Chaos Computerclub durchaus auch unsere Erfahrungen mit Plattformen gemacht, die äh einen hohen Andrang haben und vor allem einen hohen Andrang von Leuten, die wissen, wie man sowas vielleicht auch teilautomatisiert. Will jetzt nicht sagen, dass nicht auch, ne, dass,
Ticket im CCC,
ein, zwei Anläufe gebraucht hat, bis man ein sinnvolles System hatte, ne. Aber dass das ein bekanntes Problem ist.
Wird sich doch auch in NRW inzwischen rumgesprochen haben. Und es ist, es ist wirklich zum Heulen, was du da erlebst, ja. Katastrophe.
Portale ausweichen können, die sowas aushalten. Wir hätten ja im Vorgespräch gesagt, was ich so ein Event im System, was gerade wahrscheinlich nicht genutzt wird, hätte sicherlich so einen Ansturm ausgehalten.
Ja, die also da jetzt kriegen wir den nächsten äh äh Shitstorm, weil wir hier aufm kommerziellen Anbieter für äh.
Werbung, Werbung.
Aber du,
natürlich, ne? Man kann Leute fragen, die sich damit auskennen und ähm Amazon ist, ist in der Lage, äh sehr viel mehr Menschen jeden Tag irgendeine Scheiße zu verkaufen, als da irgendwie äh impfberechtigt
sind und mal einfach nur einen blöden Termin vereinbaren möchten, ne? Und wie du auch sagst, Eventim ist an einem üblichen Tag,
war zu einem üblichen Tag in der Lage, wahrscheinlich äh täglich mehr Konzerttickets zu verkaufen als wir in Deutschland,
Impftermine vergeben konnten bisher, ja? Und das ist, also das ist ein gelöstes Problem,
das zu tun, ja? Und das ist wirklich ähm es ist noch nicht mal mehr peinlich.
Somal diese Systeme derzeit gerade relativ wenig zu tun haben, weil das, was sie wofür sie eigentlich mal gebaut waren, nicht stattfindet.
Ja. Hätte man also ja, natürlich wie, ne, hätte man mal jemanden gefragt, der das schon mal gemacht hat. Ah, ist zum Heulen.
Klug gewesen, aber es ist auch zu einfach, glaube ich.
Ja
Oh man. Und ich glaube sogar, also jetzt ganz ehrlich, ich glaube, für die Anmeldung einer E-Mail-Adresse dort musste ich kein Capture angeben, ne? Also da musst du dich nicht wundern, dass das dieses System äh zusammenbricht. Ah, okay.
Ich glaube, man hätte einfach das ganz sicherlich über die Corona-App irgendwie organisieren können, oder? Du kriegst eine SMS hier an dem Tag, Impftermin, willst du kommen? Ja, nein. Und du gibst vorher eine App an, was vielleicht dein Alter ist oder sonst ist, was es für notwendig ist.
Jetzt ist also das Problem ist natürlich, die Corona-App ist nicht weit genug verbreitet. Du musst natürlich ein unabhängiges System machen und da muss ich jetzt ohnehin mal sagen, ne, die Zielgruppe sind hier.
Achtzig und Neunzigjährige und dann sagst du halt, jo, du brauchst eine E-Mail-Adresse und hier ist die Webseite und so. Also da kann man ja wirklich auch mal über zielgruppengerechte Ansprache durchaus reden. Ähm,
wie gesagt, die Person, der ich hier dabei helfen sollte und bisher nicht erfolgreich war, ist enorm fit. Ja, stand dann da mitm iPad und sagt,
Token, was soll das, ne? Aber wie viele Vierundachtzigjährige sind denn überhaupt an dem Punkt,
dass sie überhaupt dahin kommen und sagen, ich ich mache hier alles. Klar, da war auch dann irgendein PDF, was auf Impftermin NRW,
liegt, wo dann, ne, groß beschrieben ist, hier klicken, da klicken. Aber der hat sich da durchgekämpft. Ja, und am Ende kommen irgendwelche blöden Fehler.
Irgendwelche chaotischen Fehlermeldungen, die einfach nur darauf hindeuten, dass das System in sich,
nicht mehr integr ist und einfach nicht mehr, ne, die API Endpunkte einfach äh die Karten mischen jedes Mal. Ähm.
Absolute Zumutung und da hätte man natürlich den Leuten schreiben können, zumal ähm die Bundesregierung ja grade auch irgendwie hier diese Impf,
Impfmasken, Gutscheine da irgendwie versendet und was nicht alles, ne? Also da hätte man einfach einmal drüber nachdenken können.
Und sowas mit einer Online-Registrierung für Neunzigjährige anzubieten, da fragt man sich doch wirklich so, ist nicht mehr witzig.
Okay, als letztes möchte ich noch einen Tipp geben. Ich hatte ja gerade bei den Schwachstellen äh der äh von Klapphaus oder den Eigentümlichkeiten von Klapphaus in dieser Zusammenarbeit mit den unterschiedlichen.
API-Endpunkten von äh Pappnapp oder so was hieß der eine, ne? Und äh Agora ay O schon auf das auf die Forscherin von Zerforschung hingewiesen und die haben noch eine sehr lustige äh Sache gemacht hier in den
letzten Tagen, die ich einfach mal auch empfehlen möchte, die haben sich nämlich ähm ganz viele ESP,
zweiunddreißig genommen. Das sind also sehr kleine ähm Mikrocontroller mit einem eingebauten Wifi und Bluetooth Slow Energy Modul,
und haben daraus im Prinzip Corona-Warn-App bieten Sniffer gebaut, die,
sie dann mit äh Batterien versorgt haben und durch äh einige kluge, kluge Kniffe es tatsächlich geschafft haben, dass die Dinger irgendwie acht bis zehn Tage leben konnten mit der Batterie.
Und dann haben sie die in kleine Boxen gebaut und in Berliner U-Bahnen angebracht und die ganze Zeit einfach U-Bahn fahren lassen. Und äh die Dinger, diese Sensoren haben also.
Corona-Warn-App-Biekens gesammelt und weil es ja in der Berliner U-Bahn punktuell punktuell WLAN gibt,
Halten sie also auch die Möglichkeit, sich die gesammelten Beatens dann eben zurückzusenden.
Und haben das eben einige Zeit lang betrieben und da sie jetzt diese Bieken hatten, konnten sie dann von den Corona-Warn-App-Servern gucken, okay, äh wie viele Leute melden sich denn hier im weiteren Verlauf,
als infiziert.
Schöner Blogpost, weil das eben einerseits mal so, also vom Engineering-Aspekt her durchaus ganz ganz cool ist, ne, sich mal darüber Gedanken zu machen, okay,
wie kann ich so einen Sensor bauen, wie kann ich dafür sorgen, dass der niedrigen Energieverbrauch hat, wie,
was kann ich zum Beispiel machen, wie detektiere ich, dass der sich gerade an in der Endstation befindet und dort vor sich hingammelt, ne? Ähm,
oder wie detektiere ich das denn gerade im Tunnel geparkt ist über Nacht, ne, dann ein bisschen natürlich auch feststellt, okay plötzlich fährt diese Bahn eine andere Linie. Sie wollten also ursprünglich,
auf alle Linien gleich verteilt, viele Sensoren haben, um irgendwie zum Beispiel festzustellen, auf welcher Linie das Infektionsrisiko höher ist, aber die BVG ab und zu fährt dann halt man,
im Zug auch wechselt halt quasi seine Linie sehr informative Datensammlung, die ihm dann auch gezeigt hat, ja es gibt,
infizierte Person in diesen äh Bahnen und wenn man dann mal die ähm.
Dunkelziffer betrachtet und die Verbreitung der Corona-Warn-App. Dann kommt man.
Mit sehr vielen Ungewissheiten und so, aber am Ende auf die Daumenregel in jeder vollen U-Bahn sitzt statistisch auch eine,
Infizierte Person.
Und das äh ja, stärkt natürlich so Ideen wie äh da durchaus auch mal eine Maske drin zu tragen,
oder eben auch diese Art der Bewegung als kritischer zu sehen,
als sie gemeinhin äh betrachtet wird. Also das sind natürlich eine ganze Menge Ifs dran, der Erfassungszeitraum ist auch nicht ideal, weil es,
weil er jetzt hier im Winter war, wo und in Berlin und sich da ja dann tatsächlich wirklich nochmal, weil alle zu ihren Eltern nach Hause gefahren sind, zum Weihnachten feiern, äh,
nochmal weniger Menschen in den Bahnen äh befunden haben, aber insgesamt der Hack-Value dieser Datenerfassung ist einfach sehr hoch,
ein einzelner Sensor ist hier für irgendwie acht Euro zu bauen. Das ist natürlich auch äh.
Ja, da sieht man mal, wie wie billig das ist. Und da stellt man sich natürlich schon auch die Frage, warum muss muss das jetzt ein Team junger Forscherinnen machen? Warum sind solche Erfassungen nicht viel,
viel früher auch mal von den Verkehrsunternehmen selber angerollt worden.
Antwort lautet natürlich ja, die haben natürlich auch kein Interesse, wirklich belastbare Daten über das Infektionsgeschehen in ihren Wagen und wage wägenen zu sammeln.
Ja, aber jemand anders könnte man Interesse daran haben, nämlich die Öffentlichkeit und es wäre eigentlich durchaus zu überlegen, ähm
man nicht darüber nachdenkt, so was tatsächlich standardmäßig mal vorzusehen, dass nicht irgendwelche Hackerinnen äh jetzt da selber was bauen müssen und da jeden Sitz packen. Insbesondere, wenn man jetzt mal an die Züge denkt, ähm soweit ich weiß.
Sind diese ganzen WLAN Excess Points in den ICEs auch mit Bluetooth ausgestattet,
Das ist einfach so ein Nebeneffekt, weil die Technik, die sie da benutzen, wird halt auch gerne so auf Flughäfen et cetera verwendet, wo dann eben diese Bluetooth äh Technik drinsteckt, einfach um diese,
Nutzung, nämlich diese zu machen, also zur zur äh Ortung innerhalb von Gebäuden, dass so eben wo du weißt, wo du bist, wie man das auch in Museen macht. Da haben wir ja auch schon mal drüber gesprochen, wofür Bluetooth Low Energy ursprünglich mal entwickelt oder gedacht
gewesen ist. Und hier wird es ja quasi nur ähm ja umfunktioniert für äh dieses Corona äh Warn Trekking. Und,
Warum nicht einfach äh sagen
Ihr habt das jetzt einfach mal zu machen. BVG, äh liebe Bahn, denn darüber können wir ja einfach mal wirklich wertvolle Daten liefern. Ich meine, gerade die die Deutsche Bahn äh
ist halt einfach gehört dem Staat
also zu einem großen Anteil zumindest. Dann hat er entsprechendes Mitspracherecht und genauso könnte man in Bussen und so weiter drüber nachdenken, damit wir einfach dieses Risiko besser erfassen können
das ist eigentlich eine also es ist wirklich eine ich will das auch nochmal loben, also das ist ein tolles, eine tolle Idee und und und.
Extrem gut umgesetzt. Also was da äh an technischem Know-how erstmal äh erforderlich ist, aber dann eben auch diese Bereitschaft, wirklich die letzte Meile da zu gehen und das ganze Hardware-Engineering zu betreiben und natürlich dann auch einfach
konkret rauszugehen, die Dinger überall zu installieren. Fantastisch
äh zumal sie ja eben auch sehr gute Daten erfassen. Also sie sind ja sehr zeitgenau, ne? Sie empfangen ja quasi selber, während einem die Corona-Warn-App da relativ wenig Details darüber,
letztlich gibt wo genau jetzt oder wann genau dieser Kontakt war, wissen sie's halt auf die Sekunde genau und können dann eben auch,
relativ gut nachvollziehen, in welcher U-Bahn das war, wie du schon gesagt hast, dadurch dass in Bahnhöfen immer so WLANs existieren, können sie eben, obwohl da natürlich kein GPS möglich ist, relativ.
Wo denn das nun letzten Endes stattgefunden hat und könnten im Prinzip mehr oder weniger in Echtzeit, wenn man das jetzt mal richtig supportet, in Echtzeit so eine Hitmap machen
wo eigentlich,
Linien gerade und vor allem zu welchen Uhrzeiten, zu welchen Stoßzeiten am meisten Infektionsgeschehen äh zu sehen ist. Und warum soll man das nicht publizieren?
Ist halt einfach die Wahrheit. Ich meine, das ist unser Grundproblem in dieser ganzen Coronakrise ist, dass man einfach nicht öffentlich wahrheitsgemäß.
Kommuniziert, dass das einfach immer wieder drumrum geredet wird und immer wieder ähm ja, ne, dass so dargestellt wird, wie man's jetzt gerne hätte, damit möglichst immer die anderen Schuld sind. Und
genau das trägt eben dazu bei, dass wir auch uns weiterhin in dieser Krise befinden.
Also ich würde mir das durchaus wünschen, dass man das äh überlegt, ob man nicht einfach die Systemen entsprechend umrüsten kann, um einfach diese Daten einfach einzusammeln, weil das ist ja auch datenschutztechnisch, wie wir hier schon mehrfach diskutiert haben, gerade durch dieses dezentrale Modell
problemlos möglich. Wir könnten problemlos genau solche Statistiken überall erfassen und äh hätten dann einfach auch ein besseres ähm ja einen besseren Überblick darüber, wo sich eben Personen wohl so,
aufgehalten haben.
Also man muss halt will dazu anmerken, ne. Wir haben ja auch hier immer gesagt, also ein,
um spannenderes Netzwerk aus Bluetooth bieten, Sammelsensoren wäre dann eben auch ein Privacy-Risiko für ähm.
Diese ähm für die Nutzerinnen der Corona-Warn-App, ja? Ähm das haben wir immer auch benannt, ne? Jetzt ist natürlich ein Punkt.
Also deswegen wäre es gut, wenn man so etwas macht, dass das halt irgendwie nicht mit anderen Daten zusammengeführt wird, aber da siehst du natürlich auch die Power von seinem ESP zweiunddreißig, weil was der auch sammeln kann, sind ganz einfach die Wifi prost.
Ja? Wodurch du ähm nämlich dann die Daten kriegst, nicht nur wie viele äh Nutzerinnen der Corona-Warnapps sind hier gerade in der Bahn,
sondern wie viele Personen sind hier überhaupt drin? Ähm das heißt, da ist schon,
auch ein Überwachungspotential mit dieser Sache verbunden, ne? Dadurch, dass du prompt sammelst, weil du potenziell äh hier schnell äh äh an der Stelle bist, die Daten zusammenführen zu können mit Personen, also da,
bist du relativ schnell an der Grenze, aber natürlich stimme ich dir zu, der Informationsgehalt, der hier entstehen könnte,
wäre durchaus mal interessant für,
ein aufgeklärteren Umgang mit diesen Risiken. Und im Moment sitzen wir in den Flugzeugen, äh in den Bahnen und so weiter mit irgendwie Maske oder ohne. Nee, ohne nicht mehr. Ähm,
und äh lasst uns einreden, da gibt's kein Risiko, dabei kann man das eben mit einem acht Euro Sensor und ein paar Stück davon sehr einfach äh.
Einfach äh schaffen, dieses diese Erforschungsmöglichkeit. Wie das, wie gesagt, die Forscherin von Zerrforschung gemacht haben, die mit zwei Projekten, muss man wirklich sagen,
diese Woche hier in die Sendung geschafft haben, einmal eben das Anschauen von dem Klapphaus und dann auch hier äh diese,
Corona-Warn-App-Detektoren, findiges Team, hoffe ich, dass wir die öfter hier, äh, dass ihr öfter Anlässe bieten, äh, in der Sendung behandelt zu werden.
So, das bringt uns, glaube ich, ans Ende der Sendung. Vielen Dank nochmal, Daniel, für deine Kundigen äh Bemerkungen rund um die Gamesdop-Wahnsinn.
Sehr gerne.
Ja und haben wir sonst noch irgendwas nachzutragen? Linus.
Nö, wir werden die nächste Sendung äh zeitnah liefern. Äh wenn wir auch einen Gast haben und uns mit einem weiteren, spannenden äh Disaster auseinandersetzen, insofern.
Bleiben Sie uns gewogen.
Uns bald wieder, genau.
Jetzt ist die Frage, Tim, machen wir eine Feedback-Runde auf der Plattform auf einer auf einer Plattform?
Die, die nicht genannt werden darf.
Ohne Werbung zu machen.
Ich bin dabei, ja, also.
Wann wann würde wann würdest du das machen wollen?
Äh wann haben wir das letzte Mal gemacht, aufn Sonntagabend, ne?
Letztes Mal war Sonntag, das wird diesmal nicht gehen. Könnten es Montagabend machen.
Könnte ich auch dabei sein, wenn ihr Bock habt.
Dann müssen wir aber nochmal die Uhrzeit nochmal genauer skalieren, weil ich habe da im Prinzip auch schon noch was anderes geplant, also.
Oder?
Eine andere Diskussionsrunde. Aber sagen wir mal, Montagabend, da müsst ihr dann euch einfach mal in die Events äh reinschauen. Wir kündigen das dann auf der Plattform an. Die nicht genannt werden darf.
Wüsstet ihr was auf der Plattform, die nicht genannt werden darf, nicht folgen.
Genau, auf keinen Fall.
Okay, danke Daniel. Und dann hören wir uns wahrscheinlich am Montagabend.
Alles klar, tschüss.
Bis dann, tschüss.
Tschau, tschau.